[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the death nor up yo was going on Lords
of the realm what's going on fast back
OG n LG with the bronze
welcome to the roam brother good to see
you man thanks for joining you already
know and of course og Lord Jean that's
what's up man welcome to the realm of
bronze Yan said and whitey music with
the $4 super chat thank you brother man
we got 15 in headstrong screen what's
going on brother
oh I see I see I'm dead with his eyes
gun dad what's going on us girl there
yo King everybody let you talk a little
bit so let me see if they can hear y'all
make sure everything you hear me can him
shut up the levels is good we got rage
in a building you know selling everybody
you know say attic talk to little Turkey
I want make sure that people can besides
me hello you let me know everybody good
man that out will mu and then we'll just
chill out
give me some feedback y'all what's up
scrolling there's a yellow knife let me
know if yellow knife was going on audios
good Kings audio is muscle muffled as if
he's too close to the mic do I need to
back up off that how does that sound
highs levels now six six laughs let me
know you know what's going on
Shane Tom he said now he's better okay
no problem I go down those down NYC
music what up we've got shell for a
little bit we just chilling out
eat some food we will see y'all in a
minute and be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
make sure before we even start check
talk real quick low-key because you know
I just go sometime you'll make sure you
okay everybody everybody yes make sure
sometimes that OBS there's weird stuff
with the settings with yum you you know
say search it yeah just let us know real
quick before we get here you're gonna
say squirrel eBay we did that for you
here nobody tell us me oils clone so you
can everybody that's what's up that's
what's up alright so end we are laughs
welcome to the i louis podcast and the
lords of gaming dotnet episode number
155 and it's another glorious Sunday
we're back in from the roundtable on the
Lord's Day I'm very excited about our
special guest and we've got halo
infinite rumors read dad to the game
pass Xbox series eggs developer feedback
and March NPD to discuss so we go get
right into it I want to introduce a Lord
who is not only a passion and
up-and-coming content created within our
gaming community but also has the
dedication and a drive to truly reach
his potential as one of the top writers
in the game introducing the created host
of the neon God and YouTube channel
panelists of the gaming perspective
podcasts and writer / reviewer of Lords
of gaming dotnet gaming's true viking
lord of the north and the ginger bed
king is rude oh look at his room
laughs from alberta canada and making
his debut into the realm of the lord's
mommy Lord rage virus X how he do
exactly
oh I'm doing wonderful thank you so much
for that incredible intro I am so happy
to be on here today it is gonna be so
much fun
Oh Bob an absolute pleasure to have you
in the realm one of our new additions to
the team and and been killing it in such
a short time so we had to do it it's not
bad long overdue man how
you how you been what you've been
playing what's been going on in the
world of voyage virus oh really
it's been a little bit all over the
place especially with this whole Cove in
nineteen thing Oh t-virus the TiVo
anymore they not but we got we gotta be
safe we gotta protect the iPad they
protect the I am mango the thing that's
been floating around out there
interesting time but I've been doing
pretty good honestly the same busy I've
been playing a few games actually got my
hands on minecraft dungeons earlier this
week and spent about 20 hours playing
that game nominal I am so excited for
that game I'm still working on my
impression speech for that one steam to
to Lord zucchini Ghana for that other
than that and playing days gone and
started up it's come to yesterday oh gee
I heard your perspective you figure what
made you pick up ex-con to well free
play days for one oh yeah you're free
free free 99 we about that free 90
minutes free gotta play it so I'll start
playing it and I'm actually really
enjoying my time and not just that
there's XCOM chimera squad I mean I was
soon to so that kind of piqued my
interest I'm like you know I should go
back let it go back the day not for you
next time to see what the actual
experience is about I'm really enjoying
them I actually i steam on sale or
actually got on my ps4 so my just switch
over to that afterwards and continue on
there guys so go yeah it's pretty much
what I've been up to recently you know
Dom it's good good stuff always rockin
no vet says free is always a good asking
price shutout to gaming for taste
ditches happy there's no I did get no
slander cuz he can't see us with topics
out salute the stick for bad fireable
you I forgot to give me that coming in
hot I gotta give you guy coming up Eddie
you already know so you know we got the
well we're down a horseman man got to
solve man please send some love to solve
man he's definitely not feeling well hit
me up last night my brother is going
through it you know what I'm saying so
on please hit up Lord solve the iron
bank the solo gamer man he is hurting a
little bit sense some love and also real
quick before we get into that oh I want
a shout out set an aisle or put crest up
for my man mojo blues what's going on
attic I'm sorry you don't you said you
say
don't say so but you put it up for mojo
blues man he is really going through it
right now all my brother was in the chat
early from the hospital bed has some
having some heart issues
so please best sends some love to my
brother mojo blues he's on Twitter you
gone so far them on the next-gen podcast
believe with mum with my slow mods and
James Jimmy Moran so says some love to
him and we definitely give him some
positive vibes today but anyway you
already know we still got three horsemen
knows relative Lords it around for the
roundtable my co-hosts with the core
most my brother from another mother
the difficult game Conqueror Lord of
reviews and the heart of the young bull
mommy Lord addict are we doing sir
I'm doing fine I said I was tired like
maybe 30 40 minutes ago but uh the realm
has energized me that's like jay-z
[Music]
playing this ex-con game and this I
don't camera i marrow chimeratech
whatever is called Oh quite chimera
squad that might want to tell ya we got
two things going on in the realm we got
it someone that's joy so uh we got the
put the crest up four outs welcome to
the world around but thank you for first
escarpment of the go tier menu or you
are a lord
we got a twenty dollar super chat from
Smitty Smith
chapter two verse you give a rose please
accept my humble of thanks and extreme
gratitude for all the work of log-log
met IOP Kos and last book X that means a
lot say that's respect brother could
continue at it yeah but I've been
playing this for for a couple a couple
days it's it's not like how we like X
call the XCOM Hawk whoa come on let's
get to it it's it's definitely I would
say this isn't for as forgiving as the
original ex cause because I'm pretty
much like a vet at this brand like I had
these type of games I played almost all
these I can get my hands on and I had a
restart because I was
I was getting killed some hail and uh
but you know after I've learned how
things work I've learned how you know
they want you to play the game because
uh you know XCOM you could you can make
your squads the way you wanted to make
your screens right but on here there's
none of that it's like look you don't
play the way we want you to play yeah
right it's like it is a in place now
is it more um because they give you
those type of loadout so with those
characters are specific is it more
online just like a story because of the
less the thing is is like I'm used to
being able to just do what I need to
with anyone right but it's just like it
really matters because that's a v8 of
the game they're like look here's your
three people take one and they give you
this list of people three and it really
matters who you pick because it can
change the whole outflow the entire game
yes well and then they let you like
there's three enemy factions and they
let you pick one of them to research and
fight and that matters too because if
you pick one to sued you cuz I I got to
the end you know I was fighting the boss
of one of the factions and I was just I
was sitting though I did it for 40
minutes I was like I'm not to restart
the game there's no way there's no wait
hold on one second I saw somebody I'll
put up the crest up football Lord
six-layer man he's going through it too
but everybody's going through some and
r.i.p to my condolences to your on
Friday she passed at 91 thank you but I
mean that's a thank you for sharing and
sorry to hear that
that's for a story everybody that you
know um also look on my Twitter did you
know check out some of the stuff that I
drinking that I take daily you know and
cod definitely works out all the time so
I get back to it yeah so like you were
saying as far as the adjustment period
and stuff like that yeah it's an
adjustment but I to be honest with you I
think it's an adjustment that needed to
happen
you know I might appreciate the way you
know the other ones is cuz I think what
they're doing in this game is they're
building up the world for XCOM 3 and I
think these characters that you're claim
they're gonna be key people ok hmm oral
regardless to what type of welded
I don't know what type of war they're
gonna make but I do think they're gonna
be key people and it one thing I could
really give this game is it's nice to
use the aliens abilities again oh well
you get to beat them it feels so good
cuz new terrorizes an ex-con fanned by
snakes and and then the dudes that
control your mind and to be them on your
side all day it feels good I don't you
yeah exactly it's definitely interesting
because like you you'll see like sector
woods and stuff that's like the basic
enemy of exco they'll be lighted they'll
be like in jeans and a shirt they don't
what they down with us that I got these
it's weird doing stuff in the seeing
like the precautions of it like yes when
I go into a place like civilians it's
like human civilians anymore that could
be alien civilians that could the world
the world has changed
it's literally humans and aliens living
trying to live in peace in this one city
and they're like the they like the cops
they like a mixed cop unit to try to
keep and what I don't what I really
really like about is if you look at all
these characters BIOS yeah and will
literally tell you what they were doing
before the first war it was Thoth Lu
what they're doing during the war I'll
tell you what they're doing after the
war so they little they they're clearly
wanting you to know what's going off
goes there yeah because I guess they
want to build that continuity yeah - get
that reoccurring dollar which is more
the crest for Smitty Smith files of
check Christopher Hart doesn't know how
to read the book of X anyway you don't
look this battle play you had a $5 super
check from Smitty submit I would battle
Chris Hart to a battle of wits but sadly
he's he's attacking Chris on super check
because he knows Chris Hart is not gonna
go to victory with this
know why the chat is gonna scroll people
only see that but they're super chat
will be read for the world to know yeah
he would get his book eggs down but it's
out dollars on deck he said I'm going to
spend X amount of dollars today this is
the easiest W all everything try to get
my man out of enjoy you fight a
pocketwatch about this heart and he he
tweeted us something that was very
important underneath about drug
addiction and drug abuse and it was very
heartbreaking I just got a salute you
brother because I was going to salute
you alone but I definitely was gonna
salute you today because to bring
awareness to that type of plight
especially right now when we're dealing
with this situation when a lot of people
self-medicating and being locked off
from people this stuff can be very hard
on others so absolute you to bring
awareness to that that was beautiful
something you already know that has been
Lord addict yeah I've literally just
been playing there's over enough I won't
say the game has a lot of crashes I
thought maybe with just my PC I wouldn't
looked up the reviews for steam though
there's definitely some issues with this
game
know why the whole game could be played
with controller probably is like you
could easily put this on console but
that's a tough one meet all the ex-cons
patrol around where they choose to
release it in the Manatee release it but
it is what it is so I think they I think
they hate console people oh my god cuz
they keep doing this like the original
ex XCOM to wasn't on on PC yeah Xbox for
a long time and then you know you got
these publishers that after they do
stuff like that then they'll go back to
wherever they you know where they're
their company is 2k or some I don't know
why it didn't sell on console we was a
year late but I don't know why it's a
turn basement yeah the game in
perspective you got your boys in the
building you see undead I see the man
yeah oh yeah I heard you talk of
reckless or game perspective I heard you
I heard you trusted that changed my
position or Final Fantasy 7 is to go it
is part of game
yeah and now did not change my position
sir I still said I agreed with King is
that it can't win again so you know be
talking slick I heard I'm going inside
now I can win game
Oh Missy I hope I got week I got week
for a second does it and then there's a
reason it can pick it one game of the
year but I can't go I'm here because
loyalty matters X is gonna give it to
you hashtag the book accent oh of course
we had the Incredible Hulk of this ak8
the XS game oh the lord of combat sports
king of the statues it demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
ooh
beloved like a guy we do agree I'm gonna
tell you right now boys clobbering time
clobber go see that please definitely go
see that and if you did not see the last
word I don't know what the hell is wrong
with you brother
my name is beifuss on there for a
hundred listen I think God gave him the
greatest I'm coming Loki jealous the
greatest in trophies have ever given
anyone if you think God gives serious
intros to dude listen guys I want
everybody he ever gave an intro team to
go watch that show you when he's in his
bag I had the right one of my best vs.
35 bro no wife by fever said my god baby
girl he was like you're doing
like that I was like I got to rewind and
watch it again I mean I'm telling I know
you see when I want to do something good
because I watched this Kos I probably
watched some healing and I know when you
do something good you gotta go back and
watch it cause you killed that yeah you
killed so it's a look to the stories
like I gonna be talked off fly like yeah
guess lubob bro down you don't say like
if God not let y'all think it is just
statues like listen I'm tell y'all right
now please listen to King statutes
because at the end of the day no it's
not it's it's it's a breakdown of
everything like whatever that statue is
you gonna know his you don't know what
he was born as a young and a young and
I'm just getting into comic books you
know I'm sayin King put me on and I'm a
surfer guy right so when he's telling
the story of what he's talking about the
Kings about about thing and Hui for the
champion and he's telling me the Paolo's
and how much what Bing did mattered
because of who we fought that's why
please listen to kids - you will get
true history not just the MCU version of
things in a modern way you'll get the
true origin and then my man posted up
the comic books with it with the panels
and Mickey oh you and your big weird to
talk about that also so I see the bill
still well on my team the cognition
teams to load I was doing what he said
okay so here we go alright um this is
what I've been playing this week so I've
been playing got older bottles shout-out
to game passes because who did that for
you feel Dominus Maximus Spencer soon to
be a really I was at a discord they were
talking about that it was it was the
other bad bit not the one that comes the
crown he was like he was like he started
saying it and Forte corrected poor taste
like nah we ain't going that way we're
going we gonna do this right we gotta
get all the platforms all be feeling
better far as elves super check real
quick then I'll give it back to you Oh
new chapter begins out to be Phi loss of
a chattel again the pamphlet of ps5
Christopher Hart is search asserting
rewards card directly into the duel
sense to send us a good toy sorry so
check it out right I've been playing
gotta Roboto which is which is insane if
you're Metro vania type of dude if you
like Metroid in any form of fashion this
metroid is monochrome right and is a cat
who got uh he went to the planet with
his master right and he had to get to
the suit to walk around and is his
Metroid it's big guy just just get it
the formula is the same if you love
Metroid you're gonna love this
right also I was playing Momo Dora okay
love mobile door so I'm on my own my
throwback stuff but at the same time I
noticed field ominous Maximus missus
soon-to-be Aurelius yeah definitely send
something my way will deliver us from
the moon dad I stop right there because
we got Lord Jean
in the chat he said it's so good and he
has an article right now a review of all
deliver us from the moon which got kudos
from the developer who so he said it has
sci-fi production values he's a big fan
of it
so salute the Lord gene in the building
already see him in a chat we got some
great kudos Lords of gaming down there
so continued sir yeah yeah it's
definitely one that I had my eye on and
I definitely wanted to play but I went
back to tell tales right scrolled it up
the the s this weekend and I'm like yo
Batman oh and I'm in tune because I
purchased them all before they had them
on sale it was like on one thanksgiving
and when i purchased them and then lo
and behold they came out of game pass
and stuff like that mmm but I said let
me go back to these games that never
played them oh never played them at all
not not one time
right so I said let me let me get inside
these games let me see you know what
elta because you know wolf among us is
probably in my best filter felt very
classic but there's Batman they're
making another one of those babies late
I know I'll play that Batman I'm like
baby this Batman is giving them a run
for the money
because it's a reimagining of Batman
it's not the same story bro right yeah
II get to you what I'm gonna put it in I
thought I was just gonna get like you
know the Batman that I know I know
No can we split one part about his
family oh good oh no I'm saying cuz you
know it already like you do name they
did the pops is like crooked like yeah
like he's like the Wayne the Wayne
family did mad dirt and like but he was
talking about when he was at the party
yeah our blood need to stick together
yeah and I'm like what Cooney shows up
and try to shake them down oh you audit
yeah it gives you a feeling of when you
playing Bruce Wayne you're defensive
because you don't want to let them know
yeah
but you also want to stand your ground
you wanna be meek yeah I think I messed
up but I'm playing the game and I
couldn't help and marvel how beautiful
it looks and how it flowed and that was
just on my s not my ex oh you two get
back yeah so I'm like wow I said you
know telltale I think we got burnt out
on them
yeah but we're putting out some quality
stuff yeah and I really hope they you
know they come back a little bit
stronger with a little bit more fluidity
when in a very analogous city of that
poorly managed
yeah chatter he shot the squirrely did
he says season T's Olaf he just finished
season to his stories fire shot the
undead he said Batman with someone tell
tales best work
oh we got a super check get better super
chat from we got a final super chat from
a spider look man he is not my heart
it is not my problem that he spelled his
name wrong
YouTube podcast last week and he said
Xbox series X will never reach its full
potential because it releases on the
king that that's your man's you could
use let me see if all right so all right
the book of Sony will expose holy fraud
you know what first of all I love your
passion and I'm not gonna front you know
a lot of times you know Christopher Hart
comes here you I want you to know one
thing Christopher here if you have a
home here you know with where your
PlayStation dudes don't support you just
go buy that X Y s JT game Mesa cog we
missed them let me go up sorry about
that brother things are yes you alright
fire on a super GT crest up as a side
note I love classic Superman not the
opie version of today
can we go Superman classics last silver
slash golden ages tidbit hashtag no
bullets to the app okay well I did not I
did that I did to Superman statues for
you yes he did
um and I think you need to go back and
watch old episodes of Kos yes because to
Superman's is there I gave you the new
52 that's the one that you can probably
see right there with the cape on the
side and let me let me just turn this
around so you can see that Superman it's
right there your face
absolutely is the one that I did and you
can see that's Kingdom Come Superman and
that's old-school Superman that's the
broken Superman oh we got the squirrely
did and who do we get make sure I'm not
missing stuff today oh no still missing
stuff is stuff going on alright so
Smitty Smith so he crushed up two
dollars of check Chris had to copy me
lol try again he comes here every week
get up he'd up in the chat he gets he
gets you know obviously harmless joke
they don't mean anything we said over
you know we go out
he's still here oh my god you shot two
people do that did toaster that out here
that I haven't seen in a minute hazard
or gaming man I know you that went
through some medical stuff good to see
you brother that's what's up and of
course since [ __ ] some seeds that's
about oh gee that's my fest yes oh gee
salute your they know and then we got
total for squirrely Dan with the $2
Canadian Batman on Telltale's better
story than any of the movies game this
you know so far is shaping up that way
I like how to introduce his first
meaning the Catwoman I like how they're
introducing his relationship we're
hardly there um and I like how they're
doing it they're not allowing you to
bring in your preconceived notion some
people all right so is their story
they're telling you how they feel that
[ __ ] goes not canon but it's a nice
story nonetheless not and i do
appreciate it so that's all so far
besides destiny shouts at a guardian
games so cool hold on shout out to the
body in games you guys thought it was
dead
Oh shout-out to the real one shout out
to me picking up all that gold
I saw someone post on Twitter they're
like look clearly the Titans are gonna
win I'm accepting this but can we at
least make sure the hunters comfort
that's someone kissing over the joint
you don't say and then we got mommy
again JD game until I'm super track king
this is just for the Superman love gotta
love that statute Oh hold on my bro my
bro
since you two save $10 suchan love the
podcast shout-out to the forever fan
profess bros you already know bro since
you cannot come over talk about you
gonna play video games and wait around
for dinner to be served
shut up to that tweet that you didn't
guess though you know Zell Chuck says
tight gay that's what's up that's pretty
much King right that's it man but you
know I'm y'all guys I'm sorry I gotta
talk about destiny real quick even
though the last word does it you know um
you guys been telling me that Destiny's
been there for years my college bra you
see it looking pretty sketchy world
right now don't care let them deal with
those problems over there but listen if
y'all play destiny
you just hit me up cuz I'm everyday
everyday
that's what's up now you're already know
and of course we have gaming into
himself the shinobi lore cockney you
know spread that realness in the Rumba
the ILP now tell you what you want and
what you move to here so like my brother
King said make sure y'all check the best
damn pad that's the podcast all Friday
that just dropped 100 episode
man shout out to Yvonne says we made a
hundred you know passion project and
super proud we have my name is bike the
law master in the realm fantastic
discussions even if you do not care
about the game itself right now but if
you want to hear some great story some
good law this guy I mean like I said
people is asked like people want bike to
just tell them bedtime stories the voice
is so smooth beifuss he's just a savant
like what what he does
he was really humble in that partly
humble I mean couldn't have celebrated
100 with what a better guest and I'm
definitely proud to support you guys
definitely came out it was late so um
yeah man oh thank you kiss move to LA -
super chat don't a crest up kiss but I
know cuz we don't even care about that
salute mom kids move do not like that
see so salute on that but on yeah yeah
it's the same oh do the same thing like
I said trials try to get to laugh I'm
forced to my brother be afford say we
didn't get it we got to get sinister
spirits up he was lowdown until he got
his load out but I would try to get his
spirits up and get back out on rolling
onto the lighthouse on that and um yeah
what else I've been doing Oh
chimera squad you know say it's out the
cabarrus car like addict was talking
about really enjoying it nice different
take in the XCOM universe sad story
loving the fact that I could control
these aliens that have terrorized me for
four years but I do have a feeling
tactics is gonna be better I go for it
I feel coming in I was like oh I'm an
ex-con drop tactics in trouble and this
is like like that except this is more of
a side story it's only ten bucks but
it's in the universe it's a compound of
different a more compare thing would be
like an ex-con three yes this is yeah
this is setting them up of what's going
on but I go frog is tactics that be high
I'm looking at the production values I
can't waste so it's gonna be crazy and
we got Tosh I think she's a raised neck
next week it's crazy there's a lot of
good games it's gonna be good and you
know what
here's tactics I think does anyone know
the embargo lifts do not know very soon
I see I see your brother are undead
talking scandalous in here so I gotta
get him he said cog plays more than
destiny
listen man look don't live i got
receipts on you one day I heard you were
ran talking y'all know what I don't play
destiny what happens y'all know what
happens to God because I beat you sir
you and ran I got the screenshot for the
phone wolf y'all been to me really hey
listen when I don't play destiny up a
beast
it's just that Destiny's you know keeps
going okay can we talk about the stuff
you played that month to be looking at
games cause he is five points ahead of
this guy listen baby I gave it up to me
to use like your call you were hard I'll
try to catch you guys right you know
what I don't play desk I play these
games so stop switch so you can say
nothing exactly you know all these other
good pcs Danny or whatever so yeah
that's pretty much it man shouts cat
daddy shouts well I think we miss one
right you guys are being so graceful
today we can't we can't even like get
all the chat yeah I think that's all I'm
oh you know we got we got we missed on
yeah we did for mr. Mitty smurfed oldest
crest of the 100th episode was something
of epic proportions congrats and here's
to 100 more salute and my brother my
brother fawns defending me to ground
again he said Cognito be game of the
year final fantasy dude I did to get the
game with the statue
yes we got the JD game with the statue
earlier about the Superman job but we
got to get into it man otherwise we'll
be here all day brought up doubt of what
the laws have gotten to what they've
been playing all that good stuff I want
to start with Lord rage virus what do
you get you a as a writer and of course
his path to becoming a panelist for the
gaming perspective podcast and now one
of the latest additions to Lord Sagi
dotnet so Lord
rage virus let's stop in the beginning
man well with someone first video game
systems you had and what got you in the
game it all right well basically it all
started when I was very very very little
but the earliest memory I can remember
is playing on the Super Nintendo
Entertainment System mmm in some
I think it was Super Mario Bros 2 oh
listen I don't have too much
recollection of that my first big dive
into gaming was seeing Starcraft played
on PC from a Mormon missionary that came
over every day on his personal day off
and he came over to his lawn and stuff
like that and then off-time you go
upstairs my dad's office and like
Starcraft on the computer that you was
never allowed 200 thousand of all
missionary breaking protocol over in
Vancouver BC Ryu's original is yes and
if anyone found out from from dirty Dan
gone home immediately gone so every
chance I got up I went out there in
Washington play Starcraft and I was just
enamored with that game loved it in the
Louvre ever since then I've been playing
Oh as a kid when I grew up I played
Starcraft on PC and the Warcraft Mists
in the National King Miss right yes of
course
90s greatness continued absolutely and
then there's what but Star Wars game
student I play dark forces and Jedi
Knight and jemmye Knight Academy - and
all that kind of stuff made of tons the
games like that they got to a point
where we got the n64 oh man when that
came out with you got good give me some
titles maybe give me some titles Oh
banjo kazooie definitely one of them
classics you know what I love we
actually got some little kazooie since
we've been doing this you know it's all
it's always it's always some stuff that
I that you know I was in diapers or
mattek-sands because I look at that
father the jab and fuss like damn we all
like damn he's young let's go
you go ahead calm yourself down I'll go
G let's go guys the original smash
brothers those big just so you know like
Smash Brothers in my household I didn't
have any sisters have brothers and I'm
the third youngest of my family so with
one my younger brother being TVs younger
might one other brother being 2 years
older than my other brother being six
years old I mean we had some crazy
tournaments going on and it was because
we go for controllers all four of us
would be playing and we just had a blast
I think the next big stuff
step up after that would be when I got
the Gamecube we've gotta back cuz you're
not a kid okay let there's something for
the 64 I gotta ask about but maybe you
were a wrestling guy my oldest brother
and we talked about the 64 I love this
dude okay my oldest brother definitely
didn't I was actually remembered he go
over to his friends houses and they
would have nights where they create
these crazy characters out of every
single corner to like the mechanics it
was smooth game two legs action high
quality game for that time yes I did you
said brothers you said tournaments you
say 64 oh my god does that happen so it
was happening as you say that wasn't
your bag specifically yeah was my bags
by bringing up the n64 I can't leave out
one title and there's also Zelda Ocarina
of Time and Majora's Mask those are two
games that I think really substantially
yeah here we go yeah we get excited
gonna fight on the city gen Maddux I
like he just met his soulmate all
farmers calm SF from good
they're just saying old farm land up
here it's a little uh time was my first
big kind of art BG gains immediately I
think I'm really sparked my major
interest into gaming and that's really
what got me into game basically was
trying to be mean every day don't
so yeah moved on from the Gamecube after
that lovely metric Prime I think that's
the biggest one I was you know a dick
Pickman
that's another classical ooh a picnic
that was a sleeper hit um when that
joint came out because I thought it was
just like some throw away from my Amato
but that guy has fingers of gold
whatever he touches turns to gold
literally it could be some NIF not
madness but whatever he puts his eye on
he gives it that little magic and I'm so
happy that he touched the soil because
in Shalit the Danny and Dino fallacy
which an addict is like finally someone
who didn't start chasing start gaming
chiseling one stone tablet
you're cool yo yo stop why you had to
cover us like that my name is addict I
prove that message while we had to be
playing those stone tablets damn
technically we were listed gave way with
no color it was like it's right at home
I did I did for certain and then moved
up to the gameboy color in the Game Boy
Advance
so after 64 we hit right and then I had
my very first Xbox experience
no we never actually owned our own Xbox
until a few years later after original
launch so I always had to go over to
friends places now at the time I did a
lot of Taekwondo so also very little
eight years Chris to be black belt
almost got my second degree black belt
but no problems continued in our little
group there though we had um really fun
halo trainings because everybody there
big halo guy was the biggest thing come
up we there's like eight to 12 of us so
sometimes we'd have three four X boxes
up Oh
these land party certified certified now
you sort of help untold I wouldn't piss
off so many people's because if you'll
notice I trying to snake me with a
sniper and I'd be sitting there with the
SMG miss peppering them from all the
design Mendoza yeah you to og pistol
absolutely let's go hang them high blood
go cheese nuts let's go let's talk about
him any good name you so many good
memories likes to hop classic
multiplayer Xbox experience though I
just that really invented my love and
passion to actually playing multiplayer
so after that I just I really kind of
took off so mm-hmm after that it was a
little sketchy because I ended up
actually going back to PC gaming mmm I
couldn't afford anything myself so I
started building my own PC doing my can
enough to afford parts but I can end up
aiming for a battlefield 4 mm ran really
well and then played a ton of world
Warcraft in that timeframe tube so yeah
I did I had a whole online vasana with a
whole on wife when it got to the point
when it when I was spending real life
cash for farm and stuff to get low I
said this addiction has to end here I
just wanna know what end of your
addiction because here's something that
abrupt that stops you from playing that
game man yeah cuz I play the game for
seven years
Wow mmm-hmm I got significantly worse
than Dustin yeah oh really
to me it really kind of failed where a
lot of the contents became too garbled
for me there was a lot to do it even if
you're trying to be a top end Raider
because that was a pretty hardcore
Raider we went it five six seven days a
week
sort of thing he's been five six hours a
night trying to do this sort of thing
and I was a healer too so I was requite
integral you need to make sure that if
there's more content coming and stay on
top of it and really as good as I
possibly can because if you're a top
role player you have to make sure that
you're basically doing everything to the
best of your ability I even came in
second trying to hit realm first for
when kind of closing came element level
19 is you go and you do a little grind
and I missed out on the realm first
level 90 tied up like 10 minutes I was
so mad I spent 36 hours grinding and
lovleen up and it missed it by 10
minutes because I had no way you just
the conjugate way to garbled so I just
stopped I was like okay you know what I
don't really like it so it was that the
turn fight that broke to you is like
yeah I if I get that Jeff screwed is gay
pretty much man those like that plays a
little bit more like maybe six months
after that but then I got a 360 and
announced me near the end of the agenda
cycle though and it was a hand-me-down
360 with the red beating the death
problem oh well give you a red day who
did that who did not do this move
because how did I give you a rigor death
three so I could
so you know what didn't cost me a cent
another time I was me my family were
going through a lot of troubles but
Gran's divorce not long before that yeah
we were dead broke so I was like I'll
take it I'll take it so it got ongoing
this I didn't deal with that for quite a
few years and then didn't get my own
Xbox one until probably midway through
this current generation sort of thing so
I've been being playing catch-up ever
since and that really all changed when I
moved here two lovebirds with my dad my
parents divorced for because that was my
mom for about six years and I moved here
a hundred pounds underweight oh wow so
like a moved here 255 pounds I should
have been at about 200 210 my body size
and now I have 145 but mom I'm sorry 250
so I really gained a lot of my health
and weight back oh I was I was it was
bad there so hopefully when I finally
came here and I settled down because
back there I did not have a job I was
barely at home long around a lot of bad
people and so I came here got a job have
my fiancee now which me at my first job
here it's a little shortly afterwards
and we've been together for almost seven
years now actually you have seven years
this month mm-hmm and ever since then
I've been working my butt off to move my
life forward so when I've actually been
able to afford making and stuff yeah I
actually invested in it I like you so
much that I'm going where the Kings go I
don't care what platform on it my god
it's much I got a PlayStation Pro I got
the Xbox one X like I got a computer
like if it's a games I want to play it
looks really interesting meeting I'll go
out of my way to find a way to play it
fast because that's really an Indian's
what I like it doesn't matter what
platform is yeah I love Xbox but at the
same time that's because a lot of my
history has I've been with attendant or
xbox and I now find a more bigger
identity with Xbox because the catalog
and portfolio um it doesn't mean I'm not
gonna enjoy it another person in the
horn the horn to some why he was talking
he was onto something big shout names
like that serious things like that's a
game where you go the games go you know
it was definitely on to something I
could give it to your network statement
thanks Danny yeah they
I've been working my butt off just to
afford what I can and my for it and ever
since I've actually been able to have a
stable life yes like okay I can finally
get him cheap I've been wanting to do
for such a long time which is writing
The Ballad I'm talking about it goes
into the Twitter I'll gonna stop you
right there cuz you're literally
transition into the next question
literally Chase is your perfect man
again literally I was gonna say like you
know obviously you talk about the gaming
history and all that stuff and I did
want to focus on your journey as a
writer cuz you are really up-and-coming
talent a lot of passionate pieces a lot
of personal pieces to that you really
share a lot of yourself and you could
tell his shows that your writing so my
question was like you know yeah again we
clearly how you transition like what
started that what few would inspire that
passion to now put it to the put it to
the pan put it to the universe and burn
press and all the other stuff talk to me
so I've always found solace in video
games now dealing with a family of three
brothers their youngest in my family and
my dad being a police officer and I'm
not just a break with peace officer he
was a k-9 handler he handled up two
businesses at the same time as well when
she still runs to this day she used away
from home a lot of time he was working
his office and my mom was always busy
with only other brothers as well so much
you a lot of time I was on my own I had
to figure things out for myself so I
ended up going into video games and now
because I have to job in for me and
emotional connection to video games I
like to try to talk about it and
basically talk to people how it means to
me and just show how it's really
affected me over a period of time though
and being able to write about it is for
me the best way to talk about it
verbally yeah I'm actually not very good
I'm horrible yeah you got to spell it
you had to sell you owe you and your
back today you guys but salut salut to
writing being that outlet for you right
yeah allows you to verbalize these
things that sometimes you it's hard to
express and there gaming luckily that
you found gaming right that to be able
to now put that energy into the
continuum like I taught you a lot of
crap over the years
it's come to where but I have a few
mental health issues that I have to work
hard to buy packs and verbally it's the
hope though it's writing this completely
different story because they can
properly move construct what I'm trying
to think I have a difficult time for
training or in it yeah or like tying
someone exactly what I'm seeing right in
my head I'm thinking one thing what I'm
saying is different yes differently no
that's not no minute I here's two
different lists I that's still not it so
writing is the best way for me to do
that that's exactly why and I got into
it and I also do pop podcasting because
I'm not very good so it helps me my
transitions I'm just gonna let you go
cuz I'm living like you literally boom
boom boom right into my transitions
which was how did you get into
podcasting and of course the gaming
perspective podcast live with Lord
undead 3xv IRA Jackson in the chat and
of course Windows central own Samuel
tober in the middle or a No so how did
that start to get you in Wheaton with
these guys and doing podcasting then
first quick shout to all three of those
guys because they are phenomenal people
if you guys are following them having up
on any of the content stuff like that
you should because these guys are
brilliant than what they talked about
they're truly passionate gamers that
doesn't matter what you kind of think
about them on Twitter something out
there about them I will back up these
guys in the day every day because I know
what in their heart of hearts that
they're all about portraying the right
information given the proper critique
and is making sure gamers are informed
and enjoying what they love mm-hmm
that's really what we try to do as
writers or podcasters is to make sure
that we're giving you the proper
information and talk about things that
are relevant and not giving in this
information I was about absolutely
that's a big issue
brain adults it's one thing that's
that's also got me into podcasts because
when I first got into Twitter I haven't
been triggered actively very long maybe
only a few years okay um so when I first
started getting really active I saw all
this crap fun around my PC she attacks
by X oh my
well that's not true about blah blah
blah don't you and this isn't true
that's not true
but and they start chiming in training
they can well that's not true and oh
it's real I don't think it's still hard
to bleed house needs people to get bit
just nothing mm-hmm like getting to
writing and podcasting I found that as a
good way to fix the issue overall from
the very beginning of from a small step
basically from a small standpoint if I
work hard in doing what I love to do
writing podcasting portraying proper
information critique and just tone you
guys but a lot about these games I still
it's gonna grill thank you son that's
that's building the trust with the
people and that's really what I want to
be all about absolutely man that's dope
because again also trying to give us
money and even Lord on dead man you guys
weren't a very underrated podcast first
of all and in thing what I like about it
is this tough I miss and I'm like why I
didn't even catch that you don't say so
I like that you guys try to stay as
informed as possible because there's a
ton of misinformation last question I
got for you in reference to the neon God
in the soon to debut the other is so
obviously this will be your first step
into content creation officially for
yourself so my question to you is what
should we expect from this what are some
of the things you got cooking alright so
I got three kind of shows planned my
first one is the angry Canadian game
longest time and it's not going to be
anything super serious nothing that's
gonna be little short rants maybe 2 to 5
minutes long ok and I'm gonna try to put
on maybe the heart most hardcore oh you
doing a book no I don't man I want full
hardcore oh I need my AIDS I need a leg
that Canada did all that absolutely but
it's gonna get there oh yeah that's
gonna be one of those fun things because
when you come to my channel I don't want
to be I don't want you coming back and
having me be like hey everybody welcome
my channel yeah you're coming to my
channel because I want
be talking to you and I want you to be
enjoying my stuff so I'm going to be
just and everybody as everybody usually
does that would be basic thank you so
like in community rant that's me one of
them don't my other one is basically I'm
gonna do some fun voiceovers for certain
little games okay like human falls human
fall flat mm-hmm it's an interesting
looking at physics based game can be
really really comical so I played that
with kids smooth yeah yeah man so you
can get a lot of fun and they got really
creative a couple years to go mmm
playing the game for the first time so I
want to recreate that experience because
yeah I mean my fiancee was watching me
and playing the game for the first time
and I was making you know is really
funny cause she's like oh you would -
she was cackling and losing a breath I'm
like okay I got to recreate this cuz I
think you got to get out to the people
it's a bit that's that's a lot of how I
LP started people don't realize like me
King all of us like we used to do this
in party chat Sadek was there it's just
like doing voiceovers and people will
take a man proaches he was like you guys
need to do a pack like the stuff in your
party chat on like classic material so
it just yeah yeah then we got some other
dark after God we got IOP after dark
stuff like kinetic was a recording that
read it's just I have to send you a link
to see this PG version that my children
watch and you know kids get to listen to
it I want you to have a nice safe drop
is I sent that to kids once and you just
like yo interesting beginnings without
talking but yes we do understand lower
raise the voice overs do all that stuff
man
definitely upon it that's what so bad
good to see you jump internet guys one
last one please go ahead and this one's
actually my thing my most important to
do for a long time let's give it it's
gonna be a mini vlog series where I I
call it let's talk mmm and what its
gonna focus on is mental health issues
and just joking through that on a daily
basis and on its gonna I'm gonna talk
about a wide variety of topics based on
and stuff like that and I'm gonna have
people coming on with me to talk about
as well if they're willing to basically
it's just knowing that there are lots of
other people out there who struggle
every single day some more severe than
others
but in the end we are all kind of in the
same boat
and it doesn't have to be bad and you
don't have to be afraid to talk about it
- exactly that's one big thing that a
lot of people take for granted is if you
don't talk about it it's gonna sit in
student and worst environment exactly
that will create more damage for you
over a long period of time they make and
I'm speaking from personal experience
here too
that it's important to talk about it so
I think that's really one thing I want
to inspire people to do is just come out
and be willing to talk about it or not
be afraid anymore so yeah that's my goal
bra I'm loving the ambition a lot of
cool things planned and of course we
definitely appreciate the work on Lords
of gaming dotnet lot of stuff going on
ma'am I'm digging the vibe bro so mama
I'm going to ask you the question that I
ask all the guests in the realm
I need that top five video games or
franchises of all time for Lord raise
virus one let's go dark souls man
welcome back man you you in for the
Cameo you getting the kids food
privilege many do you have
alright number two metroid mending the
crime specifically crime love that game
let's go play the trilogy played all
three games from multiple times can't
get enough fire number three let's go
then gotta give it to it give this game
credit because it got me into a love
competitive multiplayer matches and
that's Call of Duty mm-hmm which one
that's my number three well just a
general whole franchise just in general
whole franchise in general but if you
want specifics Kojima refer yes oh yes
you know the original paladin boys that
was the original infinity war but then
he became we absolutely are 50 60 kills
a match with like maybe five deaths I
can make some really cool yes
let's favorite from the floor last two
is gonna be Warcraft and Starcraft
knows my absolute favorite original
Starcraft and Warcraft to load okay
weird list that's a strong list that's a
strong litter and the new addition we
gotta ask you you know say you a young
buck but you got some history there so I
gotta ask ya favorite console of all
time past a present and why Oh tough
master prisoner why tough well honestly
it is very tough but I gotta kind of
give it to the n64 honestly absolutely
you want to be a permanent classics on
there there's so many like okay all
these intended games you got today the
great not but they're all back there as
well it came the way some ways was she
perform I think you guys gonna give
credit where credit's due because 64 is
great yo Fonz going do you he got throw
up emojis he's like by the Freddie
defended position I would hear it the og
the Tendo games all annals somebody
Nevada Swansea it was a powerhouse like
majora's mask or enough time mmm you got
the Smash bro
talk tree games in general I know what
brought them up earlier before but
there's a lot of 64 like well there's a
lot of games that are on the n64 that
today I gave you an animal Mary oh let's
go yeah you know the n64 was a serious
change yeah keep it rollin yeah if they
would've went to disc route with the
silicon graphics workstation features
that they were trying to implement I
think they would have been even greater
than what they are today but you can't
front when that Muriel first came on it
is I would just run around a circle
because I was not used to control being
that precise and just seeing how it
would move you know me shouts of
controlled look like a little better
angle a different way to play yes you
know you know it's total respect for
your pick that's that's an incredible
pick especially coming from your history
of it that's like Jean right there baby
you guys turn about the n64 do you
approve rages 64 console pick absolutely
my Dreamcast got myself but day that's
what's raising a tremendous tremendous
is Wow tremendous we could talk all day
on that the chat no fuzz won't let it go
he said rage is a good dude illegitimate
but but all the systems that might have
been his greatest impact of a console 90
people don't see people realize the
impact the n64 out on the industry yeah
that zero was crazy for literally push
the entire genre yeah push the jar under
control yeah I always like from since
I'm such a co-op guy
I love they were like one of the first
systems before did it come out before
Jim Carrey had the full control is
embedded into the console it supported
playing with your friends and I believe
prior to that gene right then we have
stuff like you always have to get like
the multi-tap right this one had to tell
they're like no you ain't buying no
accessory your friends the minute you
cop this system you know saying just get
in the controller and you good to go say
it and they had the multiple color join
a they had two colorways playing
wrestling's use what they read
controller they blue control a listen
this is how petty dudes what the damn
system controller and a controller and
played a man if they move they were
moving in control if you do not have a
control that's on you so you wrote
backslash salute the rager their biggest
of great 64-bit and of course Attica
proof so we go move on and got some show
to get into last week's poll results are
in and the people have spoken to the
question about Auto wizard crown gamer
has been to me EJ in 64 was okay but
also Mike well but I think anything man
you ain't saying is trash I'll take any
last week opposed those the questions
are in with recent evidence suggesting
the limited PlayStation 4 console
availability at launch how do you think
this affects the playstation 5 when it
actually launches in comparison to the
Xbox series X the winner of a very close
for way il peephole with 38% of the vote
was big effect especially if PlayStation
5 has lower availability at launch and
Xbox is the same price
coming in at second at 30% Brooklands
was no effect
Sony gamers will wait on PlayStation 5
of build availability regardless coming
in at third place at 26 again close of
the vote was depends on if the Xbox
series X has complained compelling
software and at last place and only 5%
of the vote was I don't care switch dual
screens coming in hot
[Music]
do all the lords who are participating
sort of people all they feel that play
it's gonna have a big effect you know if
there's a low availability on let's get
gene in so gene just jumped in right
quick
you know what do you feel about the poll
do you agree with the people yeah for
the most part they got to open up
pre-orders pretty soon so they can
realize how crazy this is
yeah yeah our favor and change they
pockets a week oh my god open up all the
plugins in the world you have all the
people come down and put $100 down there
that's not 600 all the world can come
when it's time to put up and shut up
that's when the situation really is
known this for years everybody talk name
upon the time for them to get to the
show you know right now
but financially they cannot fit the bill
from the pockets so we know for a fact
that it was going to give you a limited
rollout we gonna get the money back to
the supplier and get some more green x
or more we already know how to set this
first topic off this is Lord addict one
of its favorite franchises
halo infinite man what is going on we
got rumors going on all right are we on
the I wanted to talk about the poll
question oh let's talk about the
question I when it comes to like you
needs to add yeah it's it's when it
comes to the law car I feel like a lot
of people don't realize that that this
isn't directed towards us you know I
might not have got the series but the
xbox one acts but if they were both
available to me a day one I would have
got the ax right here this is to the
people who just buy mad and into K right
imagine they bundled a la carte with
Madden mm-hmm like this is for them
because a lot of those gamers do not
care what the resolution is they do not
care what it does they're like you know
a place matter I wrap it let's go let's
go away that's facts that's facts I said
again speaking outside the box on up
side of our hardcore space right like
that a lot of casuals they do they go to
where those games also say around that
right there the date one yeah I'm going
to decimate them well I do want to find
out something that I do want to point
out so some some news right right off
the press oh we got a club he posted on
Twitter he says the unannounced project
at the initiative runs on the Unreal 4
it features various weapons gadgets and
a camera surveillance system this makes
sense given most of the xbox game
studios worse with the same engine share
tech and knowledge so I think I think
that's I think I don't think we knew
what engine that was on until then so
this is initiative right breaking news
man hold over I'll go after this code
don't want me to read it but I'm still
reading it anyway throwing up the press
for Optima scroll my bro it's just short
support to the room no need to read this
nah bruh we got a redevelop we will we
read all of the stats because you guys
have been very supportive you just come
out to click that button son that cares
we're gonna take the time up to the
readers 255 all y'all in here you have
no idea how much it means to us all
beginnings remember when it was just
like fibrinogen finally Fonz know the
game he said it really touched me like
you know we are so humbled by the
support that we do get so trust me cold
we we used to get like 15 people and
half of them were us if you know me
broken [ __ ] because you know we thought
it man is real I got mods watching all
the way from Poland yo but better watch
off we've accessed
okay salute of us other gravity those
who struggle that's real man 100% so now
it takes for the breaking news attic but
imma give it right back to you man hallo
infinite we got some juicy rumors we
don't know what's going on what to
believe but what do you think man
so we finally got a little bit you know
it's some rumors it's not really
nothing's confirmed right obviously but
we did get a little bit of rumors and
some people don't know about what they
what they wanted this but there is a lot
to talk about actually so um you know I
will go over one by one thing and then
you know I'll pass it around to the to
the realm see how you like it alright
the first thing there is is this is the
story there is one for like the overall
game there's another leak but we're not
talking about that cuz I don't like that
one you like it
addicts war that's fine man god we might
have to get an addicts world of OG but
continue I love you so here is the first
counter uh there will be 25 main
missions totaling for a 20-hour campaign
and 35 side missions for an additional
15 totaling 35 our campaign in general
when you do everything not including
collectibles Easter eggs or other hidden
goods uh skulls will return but they can
be held just like they were in Halo 3 Oh
25 main missions will feature chief as a
playable character so we'll start with
that one
ok ok so let's get it man let's get a
little rage in here first man on what do
you I mean obviously rumors grain of
salt but we gotta have some fun right so
what do you think about these rumors in
general if they are true what what's
your thoughts um they're actually quite
interesting to be honest with you and I
think it would actually be a good
direction for the game to be moving in
towards cuz recently dumi journal came
out right yes and the new much more
mobile I'd traversal system basically in
more particular Cala T and read to play
tons Holly
yeah and this one gives you more of
variety options at how you can play the
game and how you can defeat the enemies
right
if you have a feeling that hailey if
it's gonna go in that kind of direction
as well
okay and definitely with the rumors of
it being maybe an open world or I got a
hub world sort of type of game I'll be
good I think it's and I'd like to see
the direction that they might take a bit
more RPG aspects into a generation that
could be epic no let me interrupt you
real quick cuz I do want to ask you in
the terms of the possibility to this be
true what do you think that lies on it's
50/50 like again I would rather just
wait until hard information comes out
yeah just take it with a grain of salt
it could happen could not happen they
might not honestly then you never know
okay okay but let me ask you this no
does it again create a saw no you know
we don't know what the hell is true here
but your question is does this excite
you if it is true a little bit
absolutely
okay okay and that's not what you know
God you all right so you pump Lord gene
where we at with this man a lot of room
is a lot of speculation but you know
what what do you feel man what you feel
about this stuff the more it's like halo
combat Evolved the better the game is
going to be and if it's 25 missions like
halo combat Evolved that's gonna be
really great but I I'm getting the
feeling that based on the title and I'm
just pulling this out of thin air yeah
there's gonna be some sort of games as a
service element or can continue kinda
and now that's a bad thing that you know
if it's just free content that gets put
in the game all the time
what's wrong with that you know if it's
25 levels that grows to 35 levels in the
first year that's fantastic and here and
the way that's our wording it though
makes me feel like this is all at launch
it this is true like because you know
they didn't say with an expanded side
quest like especially the way you know
this next couple things you know I'll go
ahead and bring it up
they're supposed to be other playable
characters you can play people from club
on Kali Linda Fred JA Jerome and I
believe that's the dude from Halo Wars
too if I remember
you excited you excited me with that
part can I finish please
other playful characters like Kelly
Linda Fred I'm not saying Alice Douglas
Palmer Locke monk well now this is next
one arbiter that's this next one okay
kind of makes me think it's not true but
I don't know exactly a direction they're
taking this game which is a tree ox oh
now you got me because I know him you're
wrong Alice and Douglas or they're the
three Spartans it's in Halo Wars right
so clearly they're supposedly because
343 did come out a couple years ago and
said that Halo Wars the story will
continue an infinite I think that's
before the actual game even had a name
and there's a reason why between Halo
Wars and Halo Wars - there's 28-year gap
because if I Rana CLE put it like six
months after after the the events of
Halo 5 and four people you know I'm just
gonna spoil it
I'm sorry halo wars - mostly you ain't
even playing the legendary the legendary
indeed - Halo Wars - is Anders coming
out of the ring and she's looking up and
all you see one of guards one of
Cortana's guardians she says and you
hear her say I found you and it comes
out of slipspace
I know I will tell you this though like
shout-out to you for schooling me or
halo law with that the halo boys joint
because that a tree ox character just to
see if he is involved in any way in Halo
infinite I'm excited because he out here
killing spawns so it's Romi and safe and
lock easy what's he the spartans that he
fought weren't like true spartans like
yeah how goes is they had to go through
the program again there's still spartans
but they felled it the first i'll he
kill his boy though he didn't kill any
of them he just messed all the money but
he had them dragged out he dragged the
listen to like if you listen to qatar
talking to them when that's happening
he's like drums are injured it was one
of them and he's like and he kind of
like was surprised way a spartans her
was in just the way it was them or
douglas because i was stay back yeah
outlet stayed back I don't know it was
one of those two it what what I really
joy is like a tree ox is it like your
average person like it the way the way
that Isabel that's the AI talk well the
way that Isabel talks like when she does
her backstory in and who he is like this
is a dude that was literally dropped
from behind enemy lines to to just he
had one ought one mission and it was
always a suicide mission he always came
back
yeah me and you is gonna be instead of
the red versus blue it's gonna be Doug
of Rome they still be a petty with the
drill John if he said you rolls walk has
quality tools and his smart has to jump
be a logo order I'm done we ruined it
attics big right we got a stop its
timberlands
I apologize continue continue the law
pretty much what happened at the end is
you think that you're fighting a tree ox
has been the entire game but it turns
out you're fighting the shipmasters men
and that's why [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's not
the legendary ending is a tree ox
walking outside and he looks over a
ledge of a mountain with like his little
armies there and then the game was what
do you feel about these about these
rumors they don't infinite main is
Maximus
some really well there's other stuff
like apparently after you beat the
campaign you are you unlock an
exploration mode this is true they're
actually bringing elites back into the
multiplayer little armor customization
but they are along with introduction of
playable brutes but the burrito I have
customization limitations but they did
say here that the req system will not
return but they are but some of the
actual people in the story will have
some of the legendary right guns in the
actual campaign okay I think this is a
direct indication of Microsoft
admittedly was wrong with Bungie but you
know we have 265 people in the show hate
that like we give me a question let's
try to get that above 200 before the end
of the show yes sir good tuk oh yeah
because I already know game pass is a
service isn't there service right
you know PlayStation now has a service
somebody hit me on Twitter talk about
PlayStation now is 800 games but your
platform ain't pushing it all right so
we don't know is if a tree falls in the
forest we don't hear it alright so what
you need to do is the fact that you need
to go to Sony and tell them to push it
but this is how you push your service
you put your
triple-a titles your the titles that
your exclusives because everybody say
exclusive matters so you put your
exclusives where people have to go and
they can get it for free right okay so
it's not for free but you're paying for
the service but you're getting all these
games on a monthly basis I come here and
I tell y'all about game paths on a
weekly basis on what they're dropping
weekly different stuff that I'm playing
that I will never ever play Oh anyplace
else okay I would never buy it I will
never go in my wallet and buy gato
Roboto
okay I'm letting you notice right now
I'm not frauding I'm telling you the
truth I will look you in your eyes and
tell you the truth oh now but the fact
that this game is coming so I know it's
gonna have some service type of thing to
it because like like a destiny that
keeps you playing these college course
games all day long grinding and bringing
more eyes to the service is what you
want you want them to engage with your
service so yeah give give the people
what they learn with that story mode
right fine that's beautiful then give
them um mission based stuff to do with
which a man buck and Romey Rome and and
these guys so you can shape you can pick
your character you can go on to the
world in do your thing right mmm that's
a great idea but also my opinion I think
they're gonna hit it with a trifecta I
honestly believe they're gonna bring
some type of warzone type of thing to it
around right and I believe so because I
believe that's the easiest way that they
can start getting these like little loot
box type things going in you know like
like like like a fortnight's type of
thing because who doesn't want that
right they specifically set in this that
they're not returning out like they
could they could bring it back in some
other fashion but I feel like it they're
taking the rack back away I don't think
they're gonna replace it with anything
but that's just mean there might be
something else right but I do believe is
going to be a games of a service but for
those Halo
old-school heads like myself they're
gonna give you that story those people
that was crying and whining about not
playing enough with Master Chief 25
stories with Master Chief all right
that's enough for you the quell did to
stop all this man the 35 side missions
are supposed to be of those other
playable characters it's supposed to be
like you do a certain mission you want
like a couple other things that I think
the way that if this is true the way
that they're gonna do is cuz they got
destroyed like he said over you know not
connecting dots not telling people you
got to read this book this book this
article so yeah in this straight-up just
lying with the everything in the avataq
I never gave a thought process here is
we're gonna do a mission a mission
that's gonna introduce a tree ox and
then they're like alright now that
you've done this we've unlike this side
quest for you that you plays a triage
and explains why he's got to this point
between halo wars to in this game and
don't doesn't that resonate better with
people than forcing you to use a
character that you might hate you know
so yeah I think they're they're onto
something to be honest with you and and
I believe that this is the proper way to
introduce it also with being transparent
yes
you know um because it with what I know
this is a little still speculation they
don't want to wait on until they get
official yet but I understand that part
two I understand you know let's wait and
see type of thing but here we are two
two together our hyperbole on what we
want and I want this this is what I
really want is you good with this oh
yeah when they told me I'm a player's
Master Chief and then I get to check
players but later throw up dick Craig
Teddy's curly baby with the two dollar
Canadian addicts the poor white dude on
the mad real world come all about let's
be nice let's be nice you you you can
say all you want about me if you put it
in color myself he like the millions
curly bear so you can get away with
look man I got I got a shelf over there
it Jackson to the chat look we all know
you know I'm saying to me this is the
single most important halo in the
franchise like my bar has to hit this is
their flagship they are launching with
the with the Xbox series X you know
hopefully if with the condition and to
me it has to be three things you know
I'm saying and I'ma be hard on halo
because halos that way right halo is
literally what got me into multiplayer
game kind of like what Ray said in this
story we had the four TVs like LAN
parties was a thing because of me into
the console space halo holds a special
place for me and then it was only to me
stopped and like Ray said into modern
warfare came on there that kind of
cooled dough and I still played it but
it wasn't that top top dog like it used
to be for me so yeah you know obviously
halo 5 you know it's a very conflicting
thing people really love the multi
player and a lot of people are not happy
with the story and the whole bit so for
me I gotta be good things it's gotta be
the graphical showpiece so that when you
see this game you're like whoa okay this
is something next level like you've got
to attract people and I think that's the
reason they made the slipspace engine is
because they know that and they need a
better attention to do this efficient
that engine we need is thing looking
phenomenal to it I've always been a fan
of the co-op aspect of of Halo so I want
to see how that is implemented how they
rock that out
classic multi-play now that's the one
I'm not worried about I'm confident that
they can you you already got the formula
you can't really mess that up
you don't saying so I'm there but I
think if they can recapture all of those
things and I'ma be real king I think it
it can't just be good it's got it's got
to be great
I don't think it ever reaches whatever
it doesn't have to reach what it used to
be but no not to be good I'm talking
about our expectations I don't think it
ever hits our expectations for the
simple fact we live and see this is
where put that gold emoji up this is
where um you guys feel that way for
which are
call final family 70 you know 700 this
hotel right y'all feel this way because
it exceeded your expectations
right see that new goat emoji right
shout-out to graphic god oh my god oh my
gosh that's that's how it's supposed to
go
coke talk gold that's got a very put cuz
that's gonna bother me okay you got that
all left a Buick
my bad
what final fantasy came you know what we
were dealing with before in the past was
you know full motion video alright so
this game had to exceed that right it
had to reach that that level Halo came
at a time where we were well past film
full motion video mmm-hmm we're polygon
graphics now we had you know frames per
second there has to be 60 frames per
second has to have all these particles
effects but see where I thought Halo 5
was an achievement graphically I thought
you know um and you know Gary's five as
well as our achievements I don't think
the fidelity is exactly where we're
going with this yeah we can give more
on-screen right more HD are more
ray-tracing
yeah that's great but at the same time I
think content needs to be king so just
like Jing the same if it's like halo
evolved where as the story wise is solid
the story has to be rushed or a little
be solid it has to be that's right
that's yes that's what I feel in a gun
play has to be rock solid I'm with you
I'm being greedy you're saying I want
all of it you know this is like my eye I
understand what you say like if I had to
choose if you're telling me you're gonna
like y'all gonna like the poll question
okay if you're telling me out of all
those days and I had to choose let's say
you only give me two right then I'm
gonna go with narrative number one and
then I'm lost multiplayer I'm saying but
again you know if you can show some you
know 60 FPS and some rate racing
I think we definitely getting 60 frames
per second to work yeah you know I'm
saying some real you know ambien killing
some real nice particles they also will
be really cool you know because
obviously the controversy rage you know
you know what I'm about to say as far as
Xbox Lockhart and scalability and you
know people worry because this comes out
on the older platform so how well good
could it be if they could justify the
series X version looking like yo you
know I'm saying
gotta be a Red Dead moment right it
needs gas
good analogy at it you own a something
it needs to be like okay you could play
it but it Ola like that like the switch
version of The Witcher version of The
Witcher is gonna be just like that so I
want y'all to get all your expectations
in line so if y'all are y'all having s
you have an OG xbox you can partake that
bone mean is long be what you think is
gonna you know we got it we got it they
gotta have the the base s version
adequate you live with the pub G with
your buildings of the claymation Attica
that's what they need experience the
force they that's what they need that
you need to feel it why you need an X
and it was fine it's nice you could play
around in there make the jump this is
something in there for you of the right
but and they did they did it very nice
they told you that you'll be able to do
this do this do this this is a little
bit different but of the Chris for a JD
game until I said can we get some halo
you mentioned someone before oh please
please I got think I'll get the arm JD
that I don't know well since its
quarterly Danny nothing but love for ya
it's just I know it's just jokes that's
why I didn't like get you a body here
Elizabeth's go up addictions that kid I
mean we got to see more before I'm gonna
say anywhere from 85 to 90 real nice
with in 96 oh my oh my god well okay if
you take out the goofballs this is gonna
bomb it all so we gotta take scores out
to get the rolling god seriously
this is gonna happen when the
PlayStation 5 gets delayed to next year
X and X makes it on time the level of
hate don't be ridiculous bro that game
is and they're gonna be bombing it to
death oh you know it's gonna ball down
to the real scores there so if you give
me scores from real girls you know you
know real journalist real people that's
gonna put their name to instead of some
little you know oh yeah for you myself
call it crazy game whatever right so so
if we can get that I would I would
definitely go abandon me on it I
honestly believe that 343 is going to
give you the best story that they got
and they understand that rock solid
foundation they already heard this is
this is they make a break be honest
which all absolutely I think a fumble
it's right here then the bushes yes yes
I think if this game flops yeah it's not
it's not good it's not good commercial
wise or review eyes I think 343 has some
serious like changes it's gonna happen
okay good rage I was gonna say they're
gonna have to take something basic the
head shaking like what did you doing
here now sir you took all this time you
put all this effort into it you still
messed up maybe you're exactly the fit
for this franchise yeah and yeah I want
to team Bungie all day but low-key I'm
pulling for three for three I'm pulling
for them to get this right man we need
them to get this right this is an
important title let's get this which at
four we move on to the next topic he
said or did I miss my man Michael
aka apron and stop finest and wanna
build it for our super chat shout out to
King The Godfather of Xbox the book of
Acts Jesus know what it out you'll see
but yes that's our really
would truly feel this skate this this
game is super important you know to UM
to it might be the most important time
like yeah I feel like some of the other
halos is important but I feel like the
amount of damage that Brandis took this
gym they need that for more like yo have
you played a halo cuz if it is a big
attic you so right because if they nail
it you know what the conversation is and
to have a title like they forget that
low angle used to be yeah it would be it
would be amazing man listen we will see
I'm full of hope there I don't I don't
think there's ever been a game even
including license I don't think there's
ever been a game that was a that was
more of a console seller than halo was
that you're the bigger question what's
up if halo flops can Xbox recover I mean
those games are far out and it's you
know fable hypervenom table and another
remake they're pretty far out ya know
shelf a doozy for being petty I did go
to our channel cause it gave me that
next cause all the only ones that matter
yes he is on to something yes dizzy Jean
just like you're saying those games are
so far out do they get a chance to
recover like if this is if this is Jojo
joint leading it's definitely
possibility I don't I think they got a
Japanese game the first year and I think
they've got good third-party support but
yeah it's pretty bad if a little you
know it needs to be it y'all it depends
on how they show the franchise through
like how they show fate will how they
show these other games like if they have
really good reveal events and they show
enough consistency to keep people
excited about the Xbox brand and halo
flops now okay that's difference between
floppy and floppy floppy hey Louis
a good game and you know but it
disappointed a couple people they could
recover but hey look comes out and no
one's playing that they cannot recover
so he's saying he come he saying that he
takes three for three made the best halo
game in Halo 4 and he said the halo 4
stuff halo being a falling off as a myth
he says oh yeah but I have to disagree
with him on that I even have a video on
this it's like look at the end of the
day Bungie hit on both cylinders and you
can't take that from them they put it on
the multiplayer and the single player
three years three sure rage I see
thought up to 3 3 4 3 and has made a
good game with a good storyline that's
called halo 4 they've made a good game
with a good multiplayer that's called
hey I need to merge multiplayer was that
in Halo 5 single-player dig dig I got to
cut you but I think I noticed too is
that it'll start off strong and then it
kind of fades out as far as the mind
share it didn't last the way it not
gonna pass my early plan
oh yeah that's saying people are not
playing Halo but I'm just talking about
the marche in the competitive space with
the Modern Warfare's and then the
fortnight's and all these other games
that's that's lead you right to what I
was saying let's go
we're with the ok so like if they have
the three prong attack that I think that
they will use as a strategy right and
they're hitting it on all three
cylinders they or they can do
multiplayer right but multiplayer right
now is in the space where it's like pub
G okay so you know fortnight you need
that Battle Royale
type of fail you need that and and some
people would say well King we don't need
it cuz I don't play that but that's you
think that don't play that and there's
millions of kids that do my son
manly when he got his xbox he wanted an
Xbox just so he can play fortnight run
with him so and his generation he's way
younger than me generation lives briefs
eat this stuff they do that they do that
stuff so you must bring that
energy because we already have a game
that's like the game that addict like
them bleeding-edge right right
we already have that you can't do that
with Halo right so halo has to be the
open-world warfare warzone no pun
intended
delicious meal it has to be at meal in
order to get that crowd that you want
desperately yeah obviously you know
we're coming from the standpoint of we
really love you know the Xbox brand a
lot of us a really supportive Onan twee
wanted to do better and I think the only
way that it even has a chance to beat
Sony next-gen is if Halo comes out the
gate
if it doesn't I feel like it's gonna
fall behind it the other going out the
gate and I feel like they're gonna have
to have something so good right that it
just gets people to migrate in the
middle of the day this is where I feel
you order something because I feel if
Halo is a masterpiece that changes the
narrative for the series X starting a
generation if you start a generation
when an absolute masterpiece that make
people say oh my God if halo is in the
mind sure and people are saying yo you
got the plate is that's a difference to
have that at your launch title let me
just get real quick Oh JD gave a fight
on a super chat dota crest up halo will
probably be delayed and it's the best
thing for them especially if the halo TV
show still premieres next year near the
game launch hashtag handle for I don't
even know they still show the movies
still live this is a point this is a
very important I will say you know I
look fable is important gears is
important but the fact that this is
supposed to be right now launched art
yeah if it does somehow come out on time
would you know that's that's up in the
air right now if this game comes out and
it's that that critical acclaim 95 plus
game that everyone wants to play don't
get a twist that people are about what
did you are you doing for me now fax it
like the moment people are saying look
Sony Microsoft up the best multiplayer
game probably this Jim what are you
doing
it's all about writing a game that gave
us a fickle if you throw flashy candy
and it's nice that everybody raised you
know like people go to the games and if
the games are great that's all that
matters it if everyone's talking did you
see everybody's time line playing halo
oh my god I'm doing they taking
screenshots and having fun and that's
what it is the only way that Microsoft
truly recovers from the fiasco that
happened in the Xbox once took them all
generation to to backpedal to get every
student where they need to buy studios
is halo gotta come out and be lit and I
honestly feel like fable got to come out
and be lit and I don't know what they're
gonna do cares but those two games I
feel like as of right now yeah are the
most important brands for this company
right now going forward until they come
out yeah absolutely
two dollars through Pichette depends on
what you consider flung game playing
it's all three to be honest I think
sales was you know did we get the the JD
gamer yeah the delayed halo for all okay
I was just making sure I don't think
we're gonna be looking at this
generation in this same tone right when
it comes to sales because how game paths
offsets things and I think Sony's gonna
probably try to leverage our PlayStation
now could they be ridiculous if they
didn't in the same manner of a game pass
as a service you know trying to keep
that engagement level high on a on a
platform
I think game play is paramount when it
comes to this what whatever you can
tweet out and show that's ridiculous and
outrage is like like cog was saying you
have to be in the media cycle with this
game in order to show that see a lot of
you guys felt like Xbox is dead right
into a lot of people right now you know
like they like Xbox you play that type
thing and yeah I play sony i play
playstation and then they have a regular
old-school big face oh my god if you
don't even know what
don't kid triple cheese stacks taxes
here about what red did look II played
red that I play Red Dead I don't care
about what these boys there's what you
have to do is hold that guy yes and make
that guy look open what is this on my
lime ice my flies in the world go
exactly I agree
outside from perfect Shogun I don't know
if Battle Royale was the way necessarily
but in an original mode that has the
same level of energy will be fantastic I
don't think he was saying they have to
copy Battle Royale I think he was saying
they need something on that same level
as battle royal that it was when it came
out because if you can show that the X
this series X has a hundred Spartans on
the bull if you fight and you can see
the battle and EDD in cards man
I'm down with it oh we good we good we
good it could do 30 on 30 capture the
flag
it seems May 4th there's a new contender
coming again pass
that some people consider the goat some
people consider it I don't the
generation waited for this game they
sacrifice food you need to stop being so
extra for that I can go as extras I want
to go because I had to bend the knee and
purchase this game but I stuck by my
guns and in order to fill Dominus
Maximus Spencer so to be Aurelius me I
would have not purchased red-tagged we
need a shirt this that justice
soon-to-be Aurelius you hyping a
two-year-old game King what are you
doing okay what about that dude that
just brought the Xbox and he said what
we're going people were just hype in
crisis but we ain't gonna talk about
that so what is the we go what you use
Hyper Final Fantasy but I know I'm
talking about people that say you're
hyping a two-year-old game that we're
the same people hyping crisis so this is
where I'm at with it let's go as gamers
we are selfish preach or we want to sit
here there's a reason I have a work
called the Attic and you want to act
like our experiences is everybody
experiences we want to act like our
finances is everybody finances what you
can't afford that like how are you an
addict world that's exactly how the
world oh my god but for this person that
just went on abroad on xbox and got his
30 days a game past or whatever they
given inside the box and the boots up
his system and he goes into game pass
and he sees red dead - the game that is
arguable arguably the best game of this
generation for a lot of people that's
even on his panel that has come to this
show you know shout out the Fonz
he
living down by this game this game is in
game test this is a triple a banger
inside game packs and don't underst
that means every game that's out there
that's a certified hit has a shot to be
inside game pass it changes the way that
people are gonna be purchasing games to
be honest with you I just wanted to know
what y'all thought about it because I I
never thought like I never thought to
which it was show up in game pass but
it's like phil is breaking the mold we
chat then we get a range of gene and um
super chat shout out michael AKA best
our finest mm which I preach to us King
Oh hail Xbox saloon you is this anybody
I miss no all right so let's get into it
I get perfect shot alright so obviously
we got the news you know I'm saying that
um right there two men announced you
know me into game past I believe of the
self and I'll still get out Lords gaming
that Annette I believe that it was Lord
chalice you broke that for us you know
I'm salute to him for putting that up
but let's get you in a rage man where
you at with this you know is this a big
deal or people over a 10-8 like what's
up mmm I don't think it's an underrated
thing at all and it is an absolutely
wonderful game like there's a reason why
it has received quite a few awards and
why it has so many accolades and why so
many people love the game reason why I
think it's such a good thing for Xbox
know God have it is because is a great
hook in general for the service to bring
in new customers to the platform mm-hmm
so if you add big banners like that into
the service as well and they're just
starting to play games and she's wide
variety of high quality games you go
home man mmm I can combine my live
service and the subscription service
into one fax have access to all these
games to still be playing these games
and not have to worry about and continue
on this platform for not too much money
mm-hmm perfect good so if you entice if
you make that service even more juicy
makes it more enticing to people to come
over yeah and then
willing to invest more money into that
ecosystem absolutely completely
redemption perfect fit nice let's get up
Lord Jabba see with this $10 sujet
hashtag what key to remarry $10 super
trap from Lord Jasmine Jamison Jamison
okay out my apologies manager said it
made you sound like a chick I polish up
okay some people gene then you trash it
as a horse riding simulator I thought
that's what the name was I didn't know
egg the rebuttal you you are 100% right
I also anything mean it purchased the
game that's one okay so not only am I'm
going to sell that game and play it
in-game pass you like five hours for it
it doesn't matter but I wonder if
decreases the value at Gamestop if it's
on game pass probably so it doesn't take
away from the fact that other people
view the game as game of the year I
don't gain me the century game of the
generation I don't listen I'm not gonna
tell you that it's my game right a
generation I'm not gonna tell you that
I'm I will not even put it out there and
tell you you'll run out and go buy this
but if you have game pass you'll be
doing yourself a disservice if you did
not try this game at least right to try
it aside game pass that's all I'm saying
as the same way I would say play more
Medora and games inside game pass this
is a huge incentive for certain people
who didn't have the finances at that
period of time to get set during facts
to dollars super check King kill that
game pass final argument get it well I
mean what I will tell you is this right
go to the store purchase every game
that's inside game pass I'm gonna put up
my $14.99 and you tell me who has more
chips later than to buy some clothes
you just let me know what you got left
over after you did all a 900 game
purchasing I'm what you know what I got
you good good jimson said that kid you
gave it a decade a spot I Spidey and I
owe you for that so yeah yeah merely
reconciliation you know but up just get
Lord Jean man you know Red Dead the news
drop Lords a game down and put it out
there man what's going on how do you
feel about is this a big deal is this
voice it's overrated I don't think it
matters to the 20 million people that I
already bought Red Dead but I have three
thoughts about it let's get it in the
book of Acts after the chapter of 30
verses thirty the chapter four game pass
and I think the people that are on the
fence about Keene pass with people that
already had is it a good chapter it's
all one of those it's a good chapter
this convinces them of Microsoft's
commitment to game pass mmm
we fit everyone in this chat everyone in
the group here we all feel differently
about PlayStation now than we do about
game bass yes it's about the quality of
the games from there and I think it
makes you feel warm and fuzzy about
their commitment to it yeah and the
other thing it does is you know if
you're a fourteen fifteen-year-old kid
right now and you're mowing lawns or
you're a groceries for grammar a brother
then this may be the only way you play
game retains that there's so much value
there were young kids between 10 and you
know although that's probably not that
age demographic but it hey that's
neither here nor there that can that
will now get access to these games then
there's another subsection of gamers
that just play pub G they just play
fortnight fridge and now they're going
to be able to dip their toes into a
narrative driven game and realize that
video games are a better medium than
movies and television oh that's it
something yeah man let me get this super
chat real quick the living flame shout
out the $2 super chest shout out to King
for Momo Dora actually being awesome
that's what's up you know and they know
JD gamer again with the $2 super chair
I'm with you King kill it for the PS
France narrative okay
there's a lot of killing JD what's a lot
of killing today you would kill all
right cool
get at it gonna jump it or you you are
me comes to only thing I have to say
about this is look I don't like this
game I think this game is boring of this
game is to mud rages but there's how
it's got the qualities this looks
there's no denying the quality this game
is and how big this game is to go into
something like gangrenous might look
people need to realize that after a
certain by the time that games come out
any game is available to come to game
past it just depends of Microsoft's
willing to break the truck up or not any
game yeah yeah absolutely man shot them
like a punch in the end of realm let me
jump in and I'll move on yeah I mean
look I think Oh gene rage King I killed
it I think an addict of course I think
it's all it's a tremendous look and I'm
saying I think King said it best Oh in
the sense of as hardcore gamers we got
to stop just thinking about ourselves
yes we bought it we got it they want you
know say there's a millions of people
that did pick it up no doubt but it's
not about just us there's a huge market
and and gene said eloquently who just
like I said the kid that's more Lord the
kid who's just getting into the
ecosystem who's just finally getting
this console he's just got enough for
the console and that's it or maybe one
game it's more cost-effective to say you
know what instead of let me get this one
game I can get game pass get all these
games you know I'm saying
and then his people just out okay not to
mention you know I've seen multiple care
I have a friend that she does day care
well and their batons I'm over there
chillin with my my friend Evan and his
girl runs a day care and then her day
care mom will come over and it's been
multiple done I just wants not just
twice multiple times work he'll bring
his xbox and she's like well what do I
do she don't know nothing about game
don't worry he's got game pass he'll do
whatever he needs like like it works a
lot for a scenario that people don't
really like it's like I say even you
know I'm the ad world at the end of the
day when it comes to stuff like this
it's not for us not the system is not
play
sure we get it because it's cheaper
we'll get it if let me put it to you
this way it came David Moore King David
is getting stumped because it's cheaper
on his wallet what makes you think the
chip working at Ryan's ain't getting
this for her son look at the end of the
day for the hardcore game passes
attracted to us because I think day and
date attracts us right we're like you
know I got spin that bread for the joint
you don't say I'll get a gig and I think
for the hardcore like what King is doing
like I call him like the in the corner
indie gems or you know just like even
that article you put out Jamie and I'm
saying deliver us the moon that was a
game I didn't really know about you
don't say it till your article and use
like yo it's in game pass if you like
these type of games or I'm like I said
you know what boom let me just download
this right let me go check this out
something that I might not necessarily
respect that bread and I had maybe
lukewarm or partial interest and now all
of a sudden it's in-game past now it
attracts me but I think ultimately you
know I'm saying how I want to see also
how they handle game pass come launch of
the series X because to me it's a while
call it's something that they have as an
advantage coming into the next gen and I
want to see how they leverage it you
know I'm saying with s cloud with people
who get a new console it's it has some
potential image so I think it's cool why
I mean again I know not everyone agrees
you know I just want to add to your
deliver us the moon thing yeah that came
they are a pioneer very tracing and the
LSS and that's in the article that we
wrote about the game and yes if you want
to learn more about race racing and and
those techniques and you don't have to
go behind the game if you have game
paths you can if it's just a tech demo
of you playing around with your video
card and figuring out how the street
racing stuff works and calibrating your
your monitors and things like that's how
you're gonna set up you don't have to go
and buy a game to do that right
absolutely
I completely agree that's what I got on
the thing but we go a move unless
anybody got anything else on the whole I
just I just say this right over I say
when the X launch is it's a benefit
right right and people like to run out
and say that it's a rental service for
games
okay it's a rental service for games the
same way Netflix is a rental service for
movies the same way
that Amazon and in Hulu Amazon is for
music you know who lose from off the TV
shows and stuff like that I don't see
y'all having that same energy when it
comes to other rental services that you
use in your life maybe the fear comes
from the fact that you might miss the
bill that month right you know and and
if you feel this is this is what I'm
saying right you have that $60.00 that
she was going to buy a game with take
that $60 put it on a card put that
towards you get your game pass you
understand and then you extend that
period of time so I think unstable
people but financially unstable people
and this times this this is real real
right right now right now right now real
right now I drew this this I believe
game pass helps people right now and I
believe game pass is needed right now
all right so I'm playing games without
going to the store but I'll go into Game
Stop to purchase games and financially I
need that break I'll fill it you know
and it helps me to go out and buy about
food and helps you know offset a lot of
costs at this period of time right now
and I think this period of time is going
to last a lot longer than everybody let
me say something relooking cares tactics
you know like I didn't have to with all
this going on I'd have to be like yo
like I like the weight yeah like they
gave me that service and they gave you
like three years of free game best shout
out to mike rizzo opportunity i've been
like yo we got you like it's right there
like wasteland 3 come up I know I get a
play there I know I get a touchdown and
now I don't even have to get to that
time I think also I want to bring us to
rage in this sense that like what's cool
about it is they're as gamers right
there are times when you gotta make
tough choices right there are times when
three or four games drop within a tight
window and you like damn I gotta make a
choice I think game past gives you that
security blanket like okay I got this
one off the list cuz that's in-game pass
I'm good like I'm looking at next week
and I'm terrified right I got Streets of
Rage oh my god tears tactics but I'm
good you're thinking I'm like yeah
those two cheater aged born and getting
that specifically launched a gay bastard
us there so anything else that drops
around that window I'm okay financially
I don't have to expend the bread all I'm
saying all at once
and Aston Martin that is really really
cool let me get this super chat real
quick shot to give him by choice to lots
of a chat right there redemption to
better than most movies i watch great
game but that's all i got anybody else
got anything or goods theories to
Paterno please get them for me please
please okay
you read that music first we got what we
got
you want me to know all right
Christopher Hart still being unoriginal
I see the book effects there's a lumen
and a mindset if you had your own
thoughts you would know this the book of
X so we got a super Jeff JT gamer do you
think Microsoft keeps game PES the same
game paths the same with day to day does
Sony bend the knee next-gen and
eventually offered a day and if not like
what I think when it comes to that which
you know we you know Smitty Smitty you
you definitely you know appreciate what
will read the man Wolverine but you know
JD gamer I feel like it just depends on
how well it does next-gen yeah if if you
start to see a huge fluctuate between
you know install base maybe not even
huge just enough to really hit Sony's
pocket
they'll have to look into stuff like
that okay what do they have over us game
paths where do they have over some game
oh they do when they stop day and day
you I don't think you'll see big big
games you'll start to see leave the open
the open the damn up just a little bit
ready for me in the chest a little red
you want say good to see yeah I agree I
think it a pass doing well helps gives
makes puts the fire on the Sony right to
improve you think this right
Microsoft lost his generation and you
see them coming out swinging right you
see them having to do this this is not
something that is forced it from a
position of winning this is coming from
our position of losing a feeling alright
for Sony to do something as drastic as
this for you to get Ottawa to inside
PlayStation
or whatever service date they ramp it up
way because I believe that PlayStation
now how can you call yourself
PlayStation now and you get games later
oh my we got a pull-up do we add on to
something emoji in there for the actual
people you got put the audio Mogi put
the shells in there King that was epic
boy that's a messy bar is continuous no
that was epic bars don't I'm just saying
right if this is what you're gonna have
to do you're gonna have to either change
the name of that service just what's
your service action accurate because
it's definitely not accurate because
PlayStation now is it not exactly what
they're doing they giving you
PlayStation later right what what they
have to do is rebrand it and you will
want them to actually take a very early
on in order for this service to take
flight right because if they continue to
win your can continue to get you're
gonna continue to get no information
you're gonna continue to get what they
want and when they want to give it to
you right at the times they want to give
it to you Microsoft has been open honest
and showing because of the mistakes of
the past acts if it comes from losing do
not think game pass is a result of
winning are fair game pass is a result
of losing and it only benefits the
gamers now they understand but is their
bread and how fickle we are if you want
Sony to actually treat you the same way
Microsoft is tree in all Xbox fans and
you must show them how fickle you are
with your Daoist and I'm settling for a
joystick here or SSD information here
you will have revealed and show them
that by not tuning in telling you what
you want then you showed up with your
let me get the crest does show how the
fixing Vigi file out let's have a chat
in the book of Sony PS now is listed
with an
asterisk not day one trash and a sad
afterthought that's why I read the book
of eggs oh my god being messy yo Jesus
anyway that's my place that you know
they say hashtag PlayStation later
I gotta stop your yard it could show
right kicker biggest on shovel
we got the reward cuz we got to get
these topics popping man we got to get
it going on but um yeah man like I think
I am up and we have here we go xbox
three somebody gotta get the doorbell
the police so look man we got a lot of
information recently shot to just go to
window central tremendous article what
they had a chance to sit down with a lot
of devs not just Xbox and you know first
party stuff some third party devs as
well and they had a lot to say about the
series X and um you know some people are
very excited very impressed you know
about what they're seeing there was a
lot of information posted in this
article about developers and what they
are excited for the series X for the
next generation so I want to bring this
to the realm I want to start off with my
bro Lord rage virus we've been talking a
lot about this you know what are some of
the things that excited you and I know
you had some things to say about the SSD
specifically that excited you so what
you got um so like you mentioned just go
ahead and put out a wonderful article
talking with a bunch of Xbox developers
it's not just Xbox about as well X more
or less specifically - there's also
third-party developers in there as well
um it was really nice to see a lot of
them talk about what they're excited
about cuz it been waiting for something
like this for a long time because a
developer standpoint is the best
viewpoint you get for these next gen
consoles technology wise so let me go
through the article and read through it
we see a lot of praise for everything
about the series X for most part but a
lot of it also focuses on the SSD
aspects um know people need to realize
that for next year interesting in
general SSD is a big big big big deal
yes doesn't matter the high right hi
and read speed or low-speed doesn't
really matter an SSD in general is gonna
make a massive improvement now in
general this isn't just an ordinary SSD
this is an nvme SSD so you got something
you got an SSD that is designed to be
fast huge the first place right so a lot
of the earlier SSDs we're still running
off of SATA type drives which is usually
made for HT DS because H of these
external hard drives are the only large
capacity drives you can really get right
until nvme SSDs because you could own a
high-capacity SSDs if it's an N and mini
SSD ran off PCIe for yes which is
substantially I think if I remember
reading correctly six times faster than
PCIe three so there's a lot of good
things going to this next generation of
technology now there's a lot of defining
factors with the SSD as well for the
series X and um it's nice to see like
it's nice to see Jason and Ronald in the
RDA actually but over again mmm kind of
like he's actually been speaking and
talking about for a while now and it
seems a lot of people aren't exactly
paying attention so break it down it
yeah let's just say they took the i/o
speeds and the SSD speed into
consideration a long time ago focused
the Xbox velocity architecture and
around this SSD IO speeds so the Xbox
velocity architecture has so many
components into it to help the
efficiency with the SSD and transfer
information from the hard drive to the
GPU CPU whatever it really means to
process and create that game right
there's a lot of cool little features to
it as well like direct storage for one
yeah you know Hardware compression
you've got a dedicated Hardware
decompression block which is a big deal
for it it really helps out with the the
CPU overhead in general so let's just
reading correctly the neccessity can
take up a lot of CPU core usage and
if I also remember reading correctly
could take up to sometimes up to 5
course of your CPU and therefore going
with what is on the series EXA 8 quarter
CPU write as 5 of them already gone and
got three of them left over right so
they implemented something into this
which has reduced the workload down to a
portion of one core mmm which has really
alleviated a lot of the workload on the
SSD into just a very small portion so it
really there's a lot of things that have
speed up the efficiency went let's just
say they don't need to have such high
speeds to be able to do the things that
you need to do gotcha - presents the
next gen technology or changes that you
are wanting right now I understand that
PS 5 has their very very high SSD speeds
and it's being raised up quite a lot of
its like a few people yeah but what you
need to understand is those high speeds
aren't everything
it all comes down to the system
architecture and how everything coexist
together right now as opposed to the
single component of just the SSD itself
is what you say exactly no and we've
found a lot we've found out a lot about
the PS 5 and how that's assuming a
systems gonna work by the same time
there's still some software back in our
hardware and back in issues not issues
but things that we might not know about
yeah there's no stuff we don't always
know like in fairness yes yeah there's
still a lot of things to be done knowing
you gotta belt but I think what to take
away from this article is that it's
gonna be really impressive you might not
see really basically any difference
between the PS 5 or the SiriusXM oh
really
oh yes Icelanders be careful you don't
do that I am boys Dom I don't like this
what you saying
I've heard that SSD could move mountains
and and do it all that's doing the same
thing - but like what I keep being from
a special someone that has told me is
like you can have all the horsepower
that you want but if you don't got the
torque to get to the rule fair is to
piggyback off of what he's explaining
regardless what they're gonna call - the
least common
let's say the least common denominator
is the PC right yeah
none of those pcs have an SSD drive that
is equal to what Sony is trying to do
now in saying this Sony's first party
titles will be quick will be fast will
be 100% if they are not focused on the
PC but new Sony has showed you that they
take the PC in consideration though when
Jim dance moves Ryan gives the edict
that these games have to run equally are
close to equally off the board that
removes your advantage or quote unquote
set advantage when it comes to speed
also I must say that the PlayStation is
using the Krakken technology compression
technology that will allow them to
actually reduce the amount of cause that
will be used for transference of
information the same way that Microsoft
is using that their compression
technology as well so it's not like Sony
doesn't have compression technology and
they just running out there all
willy-nilly with it you know we got a
couple of super chats I think we miss
you got those I think stitch so got a
final super track from stitch hot off
the press sony announces new service
playstation later we will give you the
gays then we like it when we feel like
it earlier files which at Microsoft is a
genius they got everyone on a three-year
deal which will be over around the time
all the new exclusive Xbox series X
Games are out hashtag one dollar
argument over it was the next one then
we got a $10 super chair from JD gamer
okay I assume he's talking about you
know overall community
stop giving Sony credit for the whole
gin they didn't have any Triple A
bangers until February 2017 with a rise
in zero dawn I'm gonna give you the
whole name okay that's what they got
they got gains before
or the indication Wow indeed station
we're skirts content no hoes in my
memory
hashtag don't knows it's mine you're
right um but let's say this right
they won the gent on price you see it's
not just games alone that pushed them to
the forefront it was the game it was a
price and then it was the narrative ok
price and power I mean because seriously
you're gonna buy a less powerful system
for $100 more I mean you really have to
have something special going on up here
yeah if you're walking in the store with
X amount of dollars and is a system that
is weaker $400 more no you're gonna I
don't care what's going on you're gonna
go get the more powerful system $400 let
me guess mm [ __ ] at they better stop
listening to mark uncertain journey
his name is Magic Marx and he's using to
be messy the SSD is the vaccine for the
t-virus the pamphlet for a five-day
messy all right we go away we got do we
get sage oh no no no sage sage so we got
a $5 2% from Sudoku sage I'm pretty sure
butcher that maybe I got that right I
don't know Sony originally intended to
give the psy to SSDs and no cheap just
like that time sorry planning give the
ps3 to cell processors no GPUs and what
I think you got to put onto something
man since it's you but you via Vesey
today like you do in your bag yes
don't way I give yeah yeah addict you
look big I try for you man I try I try
we gotta get it did you finish that race
yeah we gotta give it to G in here so
series X this is D it's very good it's
very capable it's gonna improve some a
lot in gaming atmosphere and like my
whole point is yeah okay this is BS
values s DS really fast
mmm but let's not count out this series
actually just yet because there's a lot
going for it that I don't think a lot of
people understand
maybe could be just as capable for doing
less mmm no glass beats just escape me
gonna book market man I saw your tweets
man so you Twitter he was lit till it
was live for you going in on this
subject so that is what's up
Lord Gmail are they they slandering your
Sony right now I need you need to shoot
your gun back man they take they do it
too much out here I think I think we've
unloaded his whole gun by now let's go
Sony in a building north gate without
net what's up I think by the time it
matters we're gonna be two years into
this generation I think both concerts
are close enough where it's gonna be two
years before we really notice a big
difference and and the scope of the toll
we find out what Sony's doing and so
hard to say because we don't know what
Sony's doing but the scope of the
Microsoft games are never going to be
bigger than the original VCR style Xbox
X so it's going to be very easy for them
to take that GPU power throw it add all
the games in the series X cranked up
that resolution the frame rates throw
all the HDR as I possibly can they're
all the high-end audio and there's going
to be some really solid experiences in
there and there won't be any load times
at the hard drive won't mean that much
because the games will have to run right
on the very first style console mmm I
was actually just real quick before I
pass a gene did you get a chance to
check out that window central article
from Jeff Gordon where the developers
are kind of a couple of various
developers were talking about this
series X I don't know if you get a
chance to read or anything like that I
saw it but it was a couple days ago you
don't know what to believe and it is
fine I just wouldn't know if you get
caught that it now it's all good Lord
addict anything from these developers
that it are exciting you about the
series X holiday raving and talking the
does it play my games yes did you move
it on all right cool let me get the
superjet Kingdom policy which ad did you
guys see that series s mark mock up on
reddit I was the one that mocked it up
and posted it there Windows central used
it on an article while I did not see it
but I did saw I saw window centrist I
think maybe that's it that's crazy cuz
that the little white one the little
white one right it look like a little
yeah I thought let me know if that was
the one cuz I saw I did see one not show
up as Yoda will give
you the credit where credit is due um
Lord key I'm sorry somebody's talking
yeah you like to do yeah no doubt no
doubt
Lord King man anything excites you about
these developers did he do what they
talked it um everybody's excited for the
hardware
I mean it would scare me if there's
nothing new get a hell out of me but as
far as SSDs those people this this SSD
narrative that is out here that people
acting like the Xbox SSDs slow or
something listen we've seen real-world
applications of the Xbox series X SSD
right compared to an X right you have
not seen Sony's real-life comparisons to
a PlayStation Pro pro and a PlayStation
5 you have not seen this in a real game
scenario
so all this wishful thinking and hoping
and praying and doing all this stuff you
got a ax Sony to show you this stuff in
real stuff because all you keep talking
about is this little spider-man demo
where somebody's pressing fast forward
on a remote control and it's you're
going through
listen III don't believe them until they
decide to give it to somebody like
digital foundry or they decide to give
it to Austin Evans or and they step away
and allow them to talk I don't believe
them when their control narrative I
don't believe anything with them having
a little press conferences and telling
you they want your ears I do not believe
like at all until they show the level of
respect that they do for your dollar and
if you think I'm fighting and I'm just
talking from a Microsoft standpoint I'm
not I'm talking from a standpoint of who
has earned my bucks right now
ooh Microsoft has earn my bucks right
now because I actually can see and know
that they're 40% more powerful than the
PlayStation 5 mm all right and they're
willing to stand on a square this this
is what developers are saying so when
another company doesn't come out and
refute these claims
don't show their best foot forward
you're fighting against invisible
warrior because you are out here holding
a banner for somebody that doesn't have
your back and I know and and and I hear
you guys wrap the PlayStation 4 mm-hmm
live in and now wrap the PlayStation 4
because you don't have nothing but a
control oh my god - left right now you
don't know what you're repping I mean
let's be a hundred percent wrong let's
be a hundred percent honest here is he
wrong no he's not wrong the reason I
really want to stake this is family
almost in May we're gonna have a get to
you okay it's the fact that dudes is
doing a lot of Captain without any
schematic I'm sorry though it's like
when you give it give it up some people
don't want to give it up to LeBron until
the Brawn that he's the goat right there
okay you don't want to give it to LeBron
but LeBron is giving you Shawn proof
right you gotta give it up to the people
that is giving you what you're looking
for in somebody that you're repping you
got to look over and say well you know
what I don't support them dudes but they
out there doing it you know just just
give that with just give it up that's
what you say I figure we get these two
in chess before
Oh JD game went on a super chat scenario
what happens if field goes for the
jugular and takes the hit like they did
during the 360 years
and prices the series X at 399 so if my
station 5 just price if Microsoft puts
that long line in 300 no that's he said
a scenario where that's when they're
real happens you know what happens in
that whole scenario like if he goes back
he gets more than or Elias slice so
really it's a really it's really yeah
Ryan Ingram mm chat I'm going to wait
for the PlayStation 5 Pro question Bob
hashtag Bigfoot oh yeah we got sabor
addict got to get this Jonathan be
really fine there's just so many guys
being so grateful right now the PS file
we got find out super chat from from
Jonathan be the ps4 SSD doesn't even
require CPU or GPU or a box though King
Xbox doesn't have anything to match this
the level of speed pamphlet appears you
got that we got 500 super job from
Smitty Smith sturdy was up there like he
was you vo battling in the Shadow Realm
with these shadow people
JT
gamer with the fall asleep with Chad
Jonathan B tell me the last time an SSD
no matter the speed allowed you to draw
a control the character or the scream
let me answer never okay I can listen
man I get I get it we're excited we're
excited I'll just say it shout to save
all ready for me at no rush today they
going through it with John you don't
listen I do agree with King on yes you
wants your company to show improve you
want to see the transparency you know
I'm saying and I get that part he's not
wrong
he is not wrong on that part however as
I always however is it these however
since how Cognito shows up on like sony
fanboys Ryan Ingram again follow super
check you guys are late to the party the
PS 5 controller is what the control we
is the cocoa or the controller is the
console okay I guess that's why is the
dual sense oh god oh god okay I can't
look you know that's why they've only
showed us the controller because that's
that is the cops
I can imagine like the Ravel for that
like I should we showed you this
controller two months ago there's a
reason we haven't showed you anything
else
cuz this my friend is the PS 5 it's the
PS 5 - PS 6 and the PS 7 all in one
control image look how big a quick shout
they raise I love what you said about
you know we gotta hear more from them on
the intricacies of the SSD and how the
velocity architecture works in
conjunction to see how it achieved that
goal that is exciting to me yeah I want
to see how that all plays out and of
course we've got to see them side by
side shot into digital foundry leather
mini melon guys when they do the
side-by-sides but for me rebellion
excited me they had a lot to say in
reference to that they were talking
about 4k 60fps as a standard em funds
funds we know we've been going at it
Fonzie an economist and things that kind
of go at your narrative that you know
don't expect it every game but I mean he
he was very excited about that so that
was cool and then they were talking
about arm rate racing but not only just
rate racing with the lighting and things
that we expect but from an aquatic
standpoint and an audio CS raise raise
know what I'm talking about so um he
said so I think I really excite me he
said for example we can do incredible
things with the acoustics to enhance
realism modeling realistic sound
occlusion for AI hearing in real time
you said for example is an incredible
useful feature for creating stealth
games so that really really excited me
that resonated and yeah we're gonna see
man we can't wait I can't wait from you
know to get their hands on the hip hop
right right right pulled up that phones
like you gotta get here it was a lot of
bottle poverty he said what's up with
y'all stay blessed ACA must love boys if
not now is it's just that you know they
can't fight you know we know that is
more powerful that's something that
can't dispute is it's a fact right we
know what it looks like it's a fact so
we gonna deal with facts we got a
controller and we got a console that's
more powerful than whatever they show
whatever they come out with mm-hmm we
know for powerful we also know war
deniable truth Sony is Walking with
serious caution because as long as they
put out the narrative for price as soon
as they say they say 399 you understand
they have okay you know on a gun is a
bayonet right we don't on the bayonet
like is in the front yeah so they shoot
you and they won up to you this is when
they finish you off with the band right
so the series s is the bayonet once
y'all see your price the price is this
generation you're not coming in talking
about the price is cheaper not coming in
talking about you got more power you are
boxed in the corner you know what okay
or for the community for the culture you
guess it again assume all your rights it
is a bayonet with a blade she's not
feeling you right now I love joy I get
it with this [ __ ]
Lord Jeff I got another five minutes
just wanted to sweep the look for
another excellent show I walk boys are
old next week the choir all that I was
definitely Isaac today and then we got
above it a stitch finality with Jack
rest up soldier boy had more
transparency with this castle this movie
with the PlayStation what'll be the
bushes we throw them in the bushes
stitch damn that was can we at least
wait to June doe can't wait to do and
then who else we got once again we got
um like oh my god I've got Jesus I miss
a lot or night oh no one nitrous and ex
with the five pounds from over the pond
MSSD can never for a Mac for a fact make
up for shear GPU performance restore
Haiti's spot on a super check egg laying
down the law he got a defense so the
artery kick is negotiating with hip-hop
most like a good show Oh restored
Haiti's file our super check is laying
down the law like oceans coming from the
mountaintop Phil Spencer is waiting for
the killing bow or God in them all we
brought back well gotta do okay and dick
attic I need you to get gene Mauch Lewis
and the next to man still on shift F of
G mark Louis city's ex faster CPU more
powerful GPU stop ponies oh my god
Smitty Smith Smitty say we got a fight
out of super shot from Smitty Smith dan
Rose ooh I don't know I've definitely
butchered that said speed kills SSD that
is true when the rest of the body fells
because it's
unstaple enjoy this is the messiest chat
I have ever seen I love it yes I know
you do I know you do
I did oh my god Brian Ingram again with
the followers to be checked for a fact
sir dude was talking to shadow people
that's pretty much what I got as far as
you know this whole thing look
developers are excited red is not stuff
is like that bayonet its plot because
bayonet would be the talent and I know
they also they got the talent we gotta
see it look red I'm what you're saying I
say June by June we should get something
and they're from there we'll see what's
up
you know Samba I know they're and
they're my friend is the the kognito
have to be political I'm always I got I
gotta see what the competition JD you
guys have no idea what what
responsibilities put on Lord communal
well check this out check this out check
Melissa I just got the call I just got
the eat it from hip-hop game he still
set the record straight next week let's
hope so
oh definitely one comment but he was
checking in on the lords he was checking
his on Lord to give me that net you just
want to make sure that everybody is cool
and everybody's okay during this period
of time that we have it right now and
said when we when this stuff you know
alleviates when we get back to a little
bit of semblance of normalcy ass you
know go out get some dinner whatever in
the building to because in hip-hop
because I want first to say no solution
I in here is all love but we got to get
both of them in in the room together I
want that couple up in there together I
would be fired you know red hip-hop I
know you're listening let's do it I know
when schedules first of all thanks for
checking in everybody you know say you
know what the schedules get better we
got flea got to do that just say cuz you
gotta get some silly representative
running wild y'all right now in Japan
it's I could only fight so many batters
they come in anyway so salut here foul
that's what's up done deal
we definitely need that in the realm
show unity council unity you know us all
in love is all jokes we have fun with
this and it's so great to see y'all
everyone
another play when I say go I'm just
saying I'm just saying I'm just saying I
think I missed - super chance Oh JD game
of super chat look the Xbox 360 or
powerful to place into five period no
secret SSD audio chip or giving certain
your ears will change that okay we got
you and they're all jean-marc Louis -
Donna super check only thirty sixty use
that ps5 will buckle Richard on like
everybody sings we gotta move on last
topic I will speed the ball through this
because we are going late and this is
songs topic and I'll keep it keeping
small we got the all-new MPD's I'm shot
undead in the round we'll put this up
meant table knock out here taking March
man switch you know type of records mmm
is looking crazy um then we got the top
20
you know I'm said call shot to call a
duty still being number two right up for
so many moves hot and they'll be the
show number three and we know that's as
an exclusive right now eventually will
come to multiply and shout to undead for
a gaming perspective yes they made a
fantastic point when you imagine when
that goes multiplayer they could be
number one you know I'm saying when
armies farted okay we got resonate with
three round now for our 2k 25 dual
maternal six persona 5 Royale seven
Grand Theft Auto 5 Jesus Grand Theft
Auto 5 smelling never done Wow seven and
then I mean eight is gonna be Borland's
3 9 and Mario Kart deluxe really at the
10th water
in what it is is so many people because
my I have a friend he's trying to get me
to sell them my switch like because it's
that serious people can't get the switch
yeah yeah you gotta consider how many
people picked up a switch and they look
right next to him like okay let me pick
up this game we picked up the scale this
is a Mario Kart maybe that let me pick
up this game this is what I'm actually
what to bring normally I talk about
switch to open up I'm gonna let you live
today i'ma let you live well what I
wanted to say this one surprised me now
I don't see too many people talking
about it and I wanted to get your
thoughts and when I'm looking at the top
10 Xbox one games I'm watching I'm gonna
be real with Joe little disappoint it
because I saw you know Call of Duty up
number one yes resin evil number number
to do a maternal NBA 2k for grant that
five on Xbox six Madden on Xbox six Red
Dead seven eight Star Wars Jedi fallen
or a nine five for 20 and 10 minecraft
right all solid choices nothing wrong
with those games rage I didn't see Ori
to bring this to the realm
you don't say a we we've only celebrated
gamepad this purchase gamer yes purchase
right yeah it didn't okay what you're
saying digital sales there's not a
digital sell if his in-game past there's
not a snow but people could still buy it
okay rage hit that never get radiated we
could get your balls light I wanted to
bring this to you rage everybody you
have a fantastic review off on Nordo
name another um in reference to army -
which is fantastic and oh yeah I just
want to know like how do you feel about
that what you surprised about that
what's your whole thought process on Ori
to not being up on this list um
personally I'm not actually surprised at
all I didn't make it on that list just a
couple reasons here is one game Pass is
a factor in it yes people will not buy
the game outright even though for a game
like that it's really not expensive
thank you
didn't doesn't require a lot of my
exactly for me game but with game pass
you don't need to buy the game so people
just rely on that
mm-hm the other thing you have to take
into consideration is even though it is
a really really good
gave a wonderful sequin you all should
play yes what it is not a game that has
made her everybody now it is only a
metric baby again but it is kind of
there's only a subset group of people
who are really gonna have it smooth who
refuses to play because he keeps getting
lost
how can he lost that game he literally
told me he won't play because he the
feijoada kid good man yeah he honest
it's a game pass and just it being a
certain type of game that it is
completely factoring trees not charting
mm-hmm but let me ask you this dog we
gotta get consciousness we got to play
fair cuz we out here every time we
throwing up the game pass emoji and
things just lit but yeah what about
those who say okay well if game pass was
so late why any may if it didn't
encourage yourselves why people ain't go
pick up this thing well what do you guys
say to that I think that it encourages
shows to certain third-party games and
certain times when games leave but I
think as far as the Microsoft games the
longer the service is out and the more
people recognize the value in the
service and third-party games first
party games coming day and day I don't
think you're gonna see them really chart
and Lissa's like the halo the gears
forces because at the end of the day
like we can't we can't clown on
something for not being on MPD's when
literally there's a service for $10 to
played in that subscription I feel what
you going I just got a crown injury we
will pop in bottles when state of decay
was up on there what's the I think that
was still relatively it wasn't
necessarily at the beginning but it was
still at that time where people were
really recognizing what game passes I
mean since then we've got they do decay
you know they all these updates to see
at these we had gears and then we have
gears taxes coming up the the
understanding that these games are day
and day in game passes is becoming more
and more recognizable to the casual
market to the hardcore market so I don't
blame people for not buying the game
it's literally it's in there this
description
service Lord gene what is your rationale
with the Ori situation as far as game
pastor just getting past in general I
mean
MPD's a general Wichita I'm not
surprised about Ori in particular just
because of the you know the size of the
game in terms of what it is what it
really blows me away is how long take to
is doing I'm surprised to see
Borderlands back in there maybe not so
much you know Grand Theft Auto or MBA
but this heat Borderlands get back in
there was very interesting and you know
I'm surprised how well Animal Crossing
did that really showed that if kids beat
you know what I say I say you can have
all the headstart you want but one was
getting wins the race tell you right now
once their joint hit that game pass
that's when the bet is engaged we know
that you finesse to see once once that
bet is engaged all I'm going to tell you
just watch once that bets engaged you
might as well just know me the knees
overnight don't be surprised you gonna
be that face that picture with you on
your knees but look you know we know no
Tibet obviously for those who don't know
the band indeed will return if cyberpunk
enters game past then the bet between
the animal crossing and cyberpunk sales
bet between King and addict returns but
foot now continue all lower-energy all
and I have a question is that just a
calendar your bet like when is that that
end here okay so I have to wait to the
end of year to collect my name's bum
Christmas your knees gonna be wrapped up
under my tree
what you be fair you already have my
knees I'm trying to win them back
listen you're not getting them back I'm
gonna put some shea butter on and put
some ornaments on them just with
Christmas so you can see you knees I'm
gonna send your picture you knees I let
you know you ain't getting them back oh
you I'm gonna send you a picture oh yeah
I got you mostly right for the already
big yeah I mean it's at the end of the
day it's just one of those things it's
its first office it's a very difficult
game for the casual consumer you know so
I it's not for everyone and at the same
time it's on game paths like I didn't
expect this game to like sell
blockbusters or anything like missed a
super chance no it's just fake the Alice
T and found out was such a question do
you think this pandemic could result in
final at your financial resets results
again cheaper studio acquisitions for
publishers like Xbox in Google what you
did G that definitely can happen yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if like Microsoft
and Sony and Google are already talking
people like yo we know things are bad
when we slides you a little little
muddied you know you come work for us I
wouldn't be surprised that it's already
happening I'm sure a lot of these
companies are trying to save cash
reserves right Lord King you had some
explanations you wanted to give in
reference to this yes
Microsoft going forward is going to
actually revolutionize the way that we
look at MPD zombie DS is the way of the
dinosaur in a second all right
um and this is the fear this is the fear
that people are having right now because
this is the fight back this is the push
back that we have we have those people
that are brick-and-mortar dudes that
want that same oh I need to purchase
this game and I need to live in this
little ecosystem and I need to take up
shelf space home I need to collect
something
those dudes and you have to do is that
well you know the people are raised up
on services and stuff like
that don't see the value and owning
space right right now when you get to
that space you're gonna have to start
looking at engagement this is reasons
why I said that you can't look at MPD
when it comes to a game like or because
if you notice on that list
none of Xbox games on that list on an
Xbox platform right and I believe that
has a lot to do with the fact that game
paths is more about engagement opposed
to purchasing now maybe if you start
looking at what digital purchases is
going down within the purchase of a game
inside game pass right um like if you
bought if you play in Tekken and you
wanted the skins and stuff like that
you'll have to you know you you got the
main game you need the DLC but before
the game leave then you will purchase
the main game or whatever something like
that down the road so I honestly feel
that Ori is at a benefit when it comes
to engagement wise but sales wise
Microsoft isn't running any red flags up
the pole because they understand
engagement and game passes what they was
looking for they wasn't looking for Ori
to be the top seller NPD wise of that
month you know and yeah and in Animal
Crossing we knew that it was gonna do
was gonna do I think Animal Crossing
will dominate until a real contender can
step up in that space so I hear what
you're saying I hear what you're saying
in reference to a niche title in a sense
and you know whatever but my question is
all right what about we still saw a
gears up in there was still like in the
top ten or whatever whatever so my thing
is is this going to be the trend with
all going forward so you don't
anticipate them being in no because I
believe I believe um not too many people
like addict was saying when game pass
was still getting its footing I'm
starting to see commercials on ESPN and
stuff like that now so game pass was
really getting their footing right with
games I believe gears was probably the
top game like to be released into game
passive to make people feel comfortable
about the service well who said that
there was gene I said that
you know the feeling warm and fuzzy with
getting high in daring you being past so
I believe that started the good feelings
and then you get something like Devil
May Cry that was in January and stuff
like that allowed people to see them
with a richer
you know eyeballs are started to be open
along the line so more big games coming
to game pass is going to reduce the
footprint of the brick-and-mortar stores
that you know as far as physical
purchases because if you have a fear of
the game that you've purchased at full
price
coming to game pass you'll be more
reluctant in going to the store to pay
that money you will sit back play the
games that you have in game past and
trying to figure out if this game is
gonna be released if you can't wait for
the game then you will you know actually
go out and purchase the game but if you
can wait the game pass has shown you a
lot of these top tech games is making a
way to game pads at some point in time
how are they going in to hold on they
coming for you right now lads no Paul
he's like but Kate how is the company
that's selling the least amount of
consoles dictating how to market your
run and then geeky nerd small space a
tale like you talked about okay let me
let me tell you the most progressive
company is the company that's in the
rear so what you would look at as far as
trendsetters would be the company that's
behind because they if there's stuff in
the fight and they're still willing to
fight then they're going to do a whole
bunch of things when Sega lost our
disowning Sega came out with Dreamcast
right see so you have to understand it
takes losing to show innovation okay
okay so when you're saying they're
dictating pace yes they are dictating
please because I'm going to tell you to
go turn on your PlayStation now and go
play some just release PlayStation game
you're not alright so they are in a
position of leadership and they're going
to dictate pace to you Microsoft is
actually being dictated to they they're
listening to their fans and giving you
what the fans
what so if fans tell you that they will
love to have their games date and date
and if you do this we will purchase um
have you heard about what game past
sales numbers is as I believe they're
they're going to be topping PlayStation
now if they haven't bodied them already
let me get stubby give or take he's
riding with you for a ride you he said
I'll file a super chest soul he's
remember this game stopping the building
so my last Xbox one exile to door yes
the trunk deals are real two years of
game paths with GTA NBA 2k twenty and
destiny shadow keep shadow key maybe
another game six hundred and three
dollars of that truck money gone so
instead that the effects iing the
effects of of game paths as the new way
so basically what you say it in a
nutshell game just a fire [ __ ] i don't
think the chat is some contention here
this is the new transit you're saying
this is the transition from them like as
far as what they're looking at they
rather your engagement in their service
that benefits them more than the
physical salient this is what you don't
this reminds me of this reminds me when
it used to be people how to keep up with
physical and digital and then they only
kept a little physical at first for the
longest time
MPD's is only physical and then the
market changed so rapidly that they're
like look we can't be accurate with just
physical units anymore so they had to
start you know covering digital as well
right it's gonna be the same thing you
know sooner or later they're gonna have
to count subscription numbers as well
into that because the markets changing
video market before Netflix show right
room my question to them is what are you
holding onto what are you afraid of like
what is this why are you so hell-bent on
being against the subscription service
that only benefits you so I I struggle
with this thought that you would rather
pay seventy dollars to have a piece of
plastic in your hand then I have a
hundred games that you can bounce
through and do whatever you choose
that rotate always but she would rather
have that one biscuit I just want to
know what the hell are you holding on to
me personally I just love the idea of
having a library and going in and
grabbing something off the shelf and
playing it whenever I want for the rest
of my life okay and you know what I like
I like going to my xbox not getting up
off that couch and press download not
going to in shuffling and trying to
figure out and then what happens if you
got a scratch on your limited editions
and then they no longer make what
happens if you have a scratch on and you
put it in and you can't play I mean my
joint is I sit there I'm playing a game
and I saw a game I said download I like
that that's right
like it's a buffet you have a winter
buffet with mad dessert yeah I'm eating
mad desserts I'm being uh what was that
swath right now I'm gluttonous I'm see
they giving you one of those what is
that uh the seven steadily since glut
means repast is gluttony ice cream with
jello and cookies on top of my plate and
I'm like jello my ice cream and my
cookies while you're looking through the
window saying go buy this over here
because I want it for life Louis to us
who people hate what they don't have
oh my god I'll finish early we would go
along this is a long show oh that's
pretty Smith find out so much oh hey
King they must be watching their weight
by having that one basket listen man it
is choice you know I was I will be I was
surprised a little bit you know I'm
saying to see about the the Hori thing
and I just like I said for me personally
maybe I may be a king I am holding on
right maybe I'm holding on too much to
the old way of things
and as far as the sales and stuff but
you forced me into digital
no no I liked it I am digital all day
way yes I am just as lazy as you I want
the library
I want the fact that Streets of Rage
next week and and what your call against
tactics will be all my PC and all my
Xbox immediately when they launch I will
be there so I think that ain't that
sentimental but um listen I get the
argument I get the argument to Gina Gina
saying as far as the physical and I know
some people still struggle with it but
it is curious to see if the trends go
what you to what you're saying King
which is you know as gay pass gets more
in notoriety and market share and
visibility is that reflective of people
now say hey I'm just gonna stand on game
passes no need to buy a Mimi is that an
example of the market shifting so these
are all questions we got to get all Matt
back on my game at Muscatello and I'm
very curious about that would be a great
discussion point for him but that's all
I got man it's oh my god let's raise you
know radio good anyway actually you know
I got something that's unrelated to the
conversations that I've actually just
been looking out on Twitter here yes
there's something I need to warn
everybody about right now let's get it
so if you're a fan of the Last of Us
part two our major spoilers going out
right now oh footage of the end of the
game oh wow so if there's if you're part
of a meme Last of Us so I'm talking the
more light whatsoever
yeah mute yourself block people because
if you don't want these major spoilers
to ruin the game for you mmm that one
speaks mass of us peace man but you get
a box you spoil it all that [ __ ] yeah
wow that's great yeah question to get up
out of here new poll question with the
latest rumors surrounding halo infinites
future and features which of these
elements are most important to you for
the title specifically on the series X
the choices are a yes they said let me
get those boilers yo yeah Sam a
scalability
you better just get the spoiler it's
hard to tell them when you play the game
I know right halo infinite on the series
X needs to show a huge graphical
difference from current gen hardware B
new game mode or mechanics infinite
needs to do something different
solving love that 1c narrative halo
story must be epic
or D I don't care if that multi-player
ain't poppin 343 is in the bushes those
are the church history vote when it goes
up on ILP Twitter Lord rage virus Oh
the neon garden Oh God gave me
perspective and know it's it gave me dot
Nick wake and find people find you
what's going on sir well people can find
me on Twitter at rigvir underscore X and
as well on my upcoming channel than
young garden or on YouTube and all my
fun ride and stuff over at Lords of
Kenan
best damn King website say that's right
and of course another of Lords a game
that's old the eat macula Lord gene 3737
mom man what is going on with you wicked
if I'm people find you find me on
Twitter at 37 gene 37 whoa and you know
on the words that gave me that net no
doubt tell him about that Sony collar
once a month we're gonna be doing an
editorial on the position 5 coverage
summarizing what we've learned the month
of face buttons had their colors and
then a whole article he's got a
tremendous article right now review up
right now deliver us from the mold for
all platforms y'all yeah I could check
out if you got PC you want to see that
ray-tracing
go check it out if you got PlayStation 4
you can check it out if you got the Xbox
you got it in game pass right now
deliver us the Moonies got his review up
it is getting some critics and go buy it
boot right
a fast plug as always for the king I
would not expect anything less
Lord addict very good if I provide you
to go to uh sir you can find me on
Twitter
Lord addict I ope so you know like King
David you know everyone here we we
thrive to make the show better so you
know with the generosity from the super
chat wow I'm gonna be on camera every
weakness see that we've got a green
screen coming to me because I have too
many people coming in and out of my room
so you know that would be a little bit
more personal podcast because we do
anything we can to improve the podcast
because of the amazing support we get
from the community and we have so many
people in here from super chats to the
people liking the the podcast to the the
chat was lit and you know I definitely
appreciate every one of you for coming
out what is God first first first I
would like to get much respect to rage
nice meeting you brother I love the
story and and I tell people always as
gamers we like to live in this little
bubble thinking we're the only ones on
this planet doing that one thing and we
just like shrimp whereas millions of us
doing the same exact thing and you know
y'all was doing we was doing it's so
fantastic just to hear it in and it
keeps hammering home the whole thought
that we are one yes
you know we are gamers is it's not know
just you know PlayStation and Xbox it's
gamers and I'm glad that you said that
in the beginning and I love you nintendo
64 the console gene shoutout the wrong
man g yeah i i i i got a chance to meet
gene mm-hmm when we went to pax he he
braved pax this is when the carnivorous
was on the on the outskirts and i know
we still found an amazing economy a
coffee shop strong brother
so you know and he was living his best
life he we had such a great time I
thought Cognito was choking there for a
sec we we had such a great time and he
is such a great guy please read every
article that he puts up because i'ma
tell you right now when we were in
interviews he was taking notes mm-hmm
right for his articles so if y'all guys
think that we're going and having such a
great time yeah it's fun but that man
put in the grind so while we're taking
audio which is the easy part and video
is the easy part he's writing this down
to getting out there article all right
and he was sitting inside the room
putting up those articles just like
everybody else and doing the
translations and all this great stuff
salute to you sir I do respect this all
your hard work did a whole team and away
team shot to rage yes other side
conveying all the information that we
were given to you guys putting them on a
believe arm you had Eldon Ring
Lord Lord raged at what I believe and
went up and shout out to my boy Chris
Charla they gave they gave you some
kudos so it's good to see like to
celebrate you guys as much as possible
we're gonna try to bring more of Lords
of gay men down there cuz there's many
more of us and these guys I'm honored to
be a part of this team I mean to see the
growth from the site and it hits me up
all the time it's like yo this is super
impressive salute why and it is nor
dizzy you know I'm saying Lord Josh
ain't no frost and of course undead to
xvr everybody in the realm and it is
super lit that's all I got to say on it
home as far as me again thank y'all for
the support for last word and all that
good stuff support King and statues
please all that good stuff me and act
also cooking up someone got me trying to
do something for K 5 if you want for K
you know say shadow
dude he said had to give higher yeah
shot to hide the admin of the year
Hector and Josh's shout out last night
yes yo Cox dizzy man he been moving out
he's got a lot of shows he's gonna shot
podcast he was on all he's on everything
man he's only about the wheel did not
you everywhere man
well probably to me everybody enjoy
yourself fresh outro unless anybody got
anything else no we are
we gotta be out big
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]